Hey,
what the fuck are relying upon is this legitimate [inaudible] ladies and
gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you today.
Uh,
today we have one of our regular sponsors,
which is audible.com audible.com if you haven't used it.
Oh,
sweet.
Is um,
if you use the,
uh,
website audible.com forward slash Joe,
it takes you to this website where it gives you free audible for 30 days and you
get a free audio book.
And uh,
if you've never used audio books,
they're awesome for trips or for a lot of the same,
the same kind of shit where podcasts are awesome.
When you're a,
you're just killing time.
Like if you're in a car on a plane,
a difference between a great podcast or a great audio book is the difference
between a boring ass stupid fucking flight where you can't wait for it to be
over.
And something where you're enjoying the book so much.
You don't even give a shit like you get come,
I can get completely caught up in a audio book and like a four or five hour trip
and that the time just flies by and I actually enjoy it.
It's like literally a difference between not liking something,
being like annoyed by something and actually enjoying it just because your time
is just sitting in a chair taking in this book.
Uh,
so it's great for commuting.
It's great for,
you know,
for the same things I said.
Again,
like podcasts are great for,
it's great for,
you know,
when,
if you just got to ride a bike for 40 minutes,
you know,
you're gonna get on a stationary bike just to do exercise.
That shit can be really boring.
But if you could do it like with you,
there's some great music or a great audio book,
you can,
you know,
you can kill that time a lot better.
It's a,
it's a great way to get in some interesting information.
And again,
if you go to the website,
um,
audible.com,
forward slash Joe,
they give you a 30 free days.
Look who I found on here.
Oh,
the row apocalypse.
That's why our friend Daniel H.
Wilson and he's on the,
he's on the podcast today folks.
Um,
you can talk during any of this.
It doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Um,
we,
um,
we're also brought to you by death squad.tv.
That's Brian's website.
If you,
uh,
if you want to like people always ask where to get these crazy cat tee shirts
that say desk squad on them.
These are all Brian's creations and you can get him on a desk,
squad.tv and a,
the money goes to support his podcast now work as well,
which now has,
uh,
Kevin Pereira.
He has a new show called pointless on it.
Fucking awesome.
Show Kevin prayers.
Our boy,
he's hilarious.
He's brilliant.
He's a perfect guy for a fucking podcast.
We have bobcat on last night and he just finished up on a big foot.
Man.
Talked all about it.
You're going to love it,
dude.
I just like,
Joe is going to freak out,
get it downloaded it on my phone.
But before I leave here,
I'm going to listen to it on the car home outside.
Love that.
You can just do that.
I just love this world that we live in.
You know that you could just do that.
I could just throw them on my phone,
you know,
over the Wifi to take a couple of go get my car.
Boom.
Listen to it all the way home.
We uh,
we live in awesome times.
It's as a fucking bad ass.
Don't tolerate boredom.
Yeah,
we don't tolerate it and you know,
and there's,
you don't tolerate ignorance anymore either.
Get,
get your shit together.
Stupid.
All right,
the fucking information is out there.
We're also sponsored by [inaudible] dot com it's o n n I t,
makers of new mood,
Alpha brain,
true tech sport shroom.
Tech Immune does too many things to list.
Now it gets silly if I tried to list all of them cause you're not really paying
attention anymore and just getting annoyed by me.
But a,
what on it is,
is a supplement company and nutrition and fitness supplement company.
I think that's the best way to describe it.
And what we're trying to do is just sell you the very best shit possible at very
reasonable rates.
Everything that we sell is literally the lead,
the best quality supplements we can buy.
Whatever it is,
whatever we find the best quality hemp.
It's like,
it's more expensive than regular hand powder,
but it is the best shit is the highest protein ratio.
It tastes the best we have.
We mix it with raw cocoa and Maka and uh,
it's delicious.
Oh yeah.
That's a new thing we have is killer bee honey.
Uh,
yeah,
it's killer bee honey.
Why?
I Dunno.
Why not fucking scary.
Fuck yeah,
I dunno.
It's probably not even good for you.
You could get like the flux of evil bitches.
They're so evil,
those bs man.
But we uh,
we got there honey.
Ah,
we thanked him.
It's like a,
it's not some gangster honey.
Imagine if they smelled it and they came and fucked you up cause it was in your
cupboard.
Shit.
They're Telemis realized what this mother fucker's stealing all the bees trying
to fucking in the ass because you're just trying to meet you.
I don't think they would do that,
Brian.
They might think they're a little small for that,
but the idea that a,
they might come fuck you up cause you still there honey.
That's a possibility.
It's true.
Or it can make you a mine to,
there's two.
There's things.
Yeah,
I don't think it would do that.
I think you have to actually get venom the honey and the Venom Martin related.
If you get a little bit of Venom,
I think you get used to it,
right?
Isn't that what happens?
It's getting scary.
Scary.
What's scary,
dude?
Don't be scared.
They're just a little bs.
You smack them out of the sky.
I really don't think you have to worry.
I think we're talking with grading ignorance,
Brian.
So don't be scared.
It's just honey.
These fucking bees have no idea that you have this honey.
They're stupid as fuck.
They don't know about jars.
I don't know about none of that shit.
When they all work together and spin the wheel,
dude,
you do not have to worry about that cap off.
Get yourself some vitamin sons,
Alpha brain,
throw down some kettlebells and get all manly.
Um,
if you want to buy kettlebells,
we have the best quality kettle bells that we can sell the cheapest possible
rates.
It's a,
it's a like a very problematic thing to sell kettle bells,
you know,
to be a small company and try to sell them because it's all about the shipping.
You're,
you're sending these giant steel balls in the mail and,
but we're,
we're,
we're getting the best quality shit.
When you buy your,
you don't ever have to replace it.
They last forever.
At least the fucking things are amazingly well made and there's some of the best
workouts you can ever do as far as functional strength and fitness as far as,
uh,
the ability to apply it in sports and athletics.
I think the kettle bells are the best.
I think it's,
uh,
one of my favorite things to do.
You don't really need like that much exercise equipment.
You can do body weight squats,
Chin ups and Kettlebell exercises and it's like,
it's really almost all you need.
If you want to be a bad motherfucker like Brian Red van,
aren't you Kettlebell and Brian?
No.
No candle to make sure my cat's not paying on my couch.
Right.
That's the really,
that's the hard thing in Brian's life.
Uh,
use the code named Rogan and save 10% off,
10% off any and all of the on it supplements.
All right.
You dirty bitches.
Jenny Wilson's here wanting to get down to business.
We're going to find about robots and shit and whether or not we should be
freaking out right now.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Powerful.
Daniel H.
Wilson.
How are you a robotics expert?
He do,
uh,
it was it all in research for this book?
Do you have a background in robotics?
Yeah.
As a kid I got really into robots and then I,
uh,
I studied computer science and then while I was doing that,
I found out that instead of just programming computers,
you could actually teach them how to learn the answer on their own artificial
intelligence.
So when I saw it like that there was science fiction that you could study for
real,
uh,
the nerd in me really went for it.
I mean it was really,
it was exactly like if you're playing a role playing game and you have a
character sheet and you're picking the skills.
I saw roboticist and I said,
oh well I'll love lump in that.
I think that that would be great.
So it was just like you,
you had a dream job as a little kid and you just got lucky that it was an actual
real job.
Yeah,
basically.
I mean like I like science fiction.
I like the science.
And then whenever I got,
when I finished this computer science thing and I didn't want to,
I think,
forget going into the real world and get a job screen.
So fuck that.
I went to Grad school and studied robotics.
Uh,
and when I finished that I started writing books about robots.
Wow,
that's awesome.
Um,
this book that you wrote,
robot apocalypse,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
This is going to get turned into a movie.
Scare the fuck out of people,
man.
You know,
I've had,
I've had this describe to me at from very credible sources as saving private
Ryan with the robots.
It's going to be fucking intense.
Is this something that you
just wrote about it because it's a fascinating piece of,
of fiction to pursue or is this something that you think is actually possible?
Do you,
do you ever consider the idea that robots could try to take over the earth?
Well,
man,
I have really mixed feelings about this because like I spent all this time with
roboticists,
we're building robots,
we all had our own research and we're definitely trying to help people.
None of us were evil
that I knew of,
you know?
And so then I go and I get done and I write this book were were robots are like
killing everybody,
you know,
so I made it as realistic as I could based on everything I know.
So there are no robust amount of space,
there's no time travel.
There's this is all based on stuff that we either have already or we're gonna
have soon.
So it's the most realistic version of that I could come up with.
But that said,
I don't really think that the robots are going to,
you know,
join together under a sentience artificial intelligence and then try to wipe us
out as a species.
I always wonder,
because I always felt like there was certain things that the instincts that
human beings had that lead us to war and lead us to,
um,
to feats of ego and craziness and psychosis.
And I always felt the day we're a,
a lot of them were wrapped around breeding around the,
the necessary things that need to be in place in order to reinforce the idea
that there's con it's competition to breed and that these things wouldn't exist
in a computer because it,
it wouldn't need them.
It wouldn't be inherent to the system.
The same way greed and ego.
It was almost inherent to the human system to promote sexual conquest or tour to
promote competition.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at any of us that are sitting here that are alive,
you've got to think that every single one of our ancestors by hook or by Crook,
they live long enough to make babies.
You have to keep the babies say,
and so you don't get,
you don't make it that long.
Like 200,000 years of Homo sapiens without being a bad ass.
Right?
Anybody that was a little too soft,
they're not here.
You know,
they didn't,
they didn't make babies.
And so that is a part of our DNA,
literally,
you know,
as human beings.
And the thing about building robots is,
I mean you can make them any way you want,
right?
If you want to build a robot that's going to have a self present,
a sense of self preservation,
you can do that.
You know,
that's,
well there was also the crazy thought that in this pursuit,
this mad pursuit of success that a,
that pushes people to do war and pushes people to,
uh,
to for with great feats of Ego,
this,
it's almost like that's necessary to ensure that there's some form of
competition to make things move in the right direction to do that.
But that doesn't seem like that would be inherent in a computer system.
I think they do,
she human behavior,
like we shouldn't think that it would like say,
oh,
we've got to wipe out all of these people we have to take over and wipe out all
these people.
It doesn't even seem like it would have like a desire to compete.
See,
see,
here's the deal.
Like human beings,
I feel like we've got all this machinery that's in place has been for a long
time because it works,
right?
There's a reason we're all still alive.
And so we have a nature,
we have a human nature that we can't change.
And sometimes it pushes us to do terrible things in to survive or,
or you know this,
like you're talking about conquest and that's scary,
right?
That were each of us fighting against sort of a dark nature and we've all got
the potential to have a good nature.
I think what's even more scary than that is that a robot can be a total blank
slate.
Let's say you tell a robot to solve a problem.
You tell it to get from point a to point B.
Well,
if that involves like stepping on babies,
a robot doesn't have any nature,
it doesn't have any instinct.
It'll do that.
It'll commit in an amoral way without any good or evil associated with it.
It can commit atrocities,
you know?
And that's pretty scary.
I mean,
that means you gotta be careful whenever you build these things.
Yeah,
that's,
you mean you can build into it.
Please avoid humans,
avoid,
you know,
unnecessary loss of human life.
But at a,
at a certain point in time,
if you're gonna use like one of those for war,
like we're kind of doing with,
with drones.
I mean that's kind of essentially what a drone is,
right?
It's like a robot that flies.
Yeah.
Drone has a lot of autonomy.
It makes some decisions on its own,
but there's,
but they're not pulling the trigger themselves.
I don't think they're doing that.
There are,
by the way,
people get all upset about drones and autonomous weapons have been around for
four decades and decades.
I mean the very first drone,
I think they use it in the Korean War,
so you know,
and then Vietnam,
they had them,
now they're getting cheap cause we've got the cheap sensors,
cheap processing.
Well that was one of the,
uh,
part particulars in operation Northwoods I think was that they were going to use
a drone jetliner and we're going to blow it up and blamed the Cubans.
Cubans blew up a Atlanta and back then they could just like fucking change your
life.
You now Joe Hill and you live in Montgomery,
Alabama.
No,
you just moved there.
You know,
and they uh,
that was,
they had drones back then,
which is,
that's nuts.
That's like 1962 or something like that.
61 whatever it was.
Yeah.
You just load up a vehicle with a,
with a bunch of explosives and a rock on the gas pedal.
I mean that's,
I wonder if they knew how to land them or they just knew how to take them off.
I wonder,
you know what I mean?
It's a drone like jumbo jet.
I wonder,
I wonder what they actually knew how to do back then if they could actually land
it at.
One thing I've always wondered is if you're driving a drone all day,
you know,
and you're like,
are the,
the human being that does pull the trigger?
Like wouldn't it be nicer for the government to put like a big black sensor bar
like over it before you see all the little people get turned into chunks of meat
just for your own sanity?
I don't think we'll do,
they look at it through that night vision,
that thermal stuff.
Right.
Dude,
that's weird to watch this video for you.
The crazy thing is you,
you hear the guys,
they speak so clinically,
right?
They're like,
okay,
engage target dude to Duke.
And it sounded like airline pilots and then they pull that trigger and you,
uh,
you hear the guns firing cause you're there inside the Apache helicopter,
whatever.
And then it actually like five seconds
for the bullets to go like two miles and then all the little people start flying
around.
It's pretty crazy.
It was bizarre.
It's bizarre.
I mean,
it's just the weirdest way of eliminating people.
it's so clinical and it's so detached,
you know?
It's like weird.
You know,
we're killing people from like a mile away.
What's a landmine though,
right?
I mean,
a landmine is basically a robot,
right?
To define robots.
When people ask me,
I always say it's any kind of mechanical artifact that senses the environment,
thinks about what to do and an ax on its own and does the whole sense think,
act,
deal.
And that's what a landmine does.
It sits around and senses think weights on a human whenever a human steps on it
thinks,
makes a simple decision to explode.
Wow.
Yeah.
How many of those are loud on through a bunch of round from like the Vietnam
more that's,
they still haven't detonated yet.
I don't think the United States is allowed.
I don't think,
I think they're outlawed on it and I'm pretty sure that we conform to that and
most circumstances.
But yeah,
there's a ton of them that are left and,
and there's not just land mines,
right?
There's uh,
there's underwater mines for,
for submarines,
right.
So they hang out on the bottom of the ocean and they are able to,
this is what's interesting.
They do,
these are old too.
These are from the 60s the,
they can target nuclear submarines and these land mines are complicated as shit.
So they sit there and they listened for the acoustic signature of whatever comes
past and then they identify what type of craft it is based on that.
They choose different like loitering strategies about how to follow it and how
to get close enough to detonate.
And then they,
then they chase and then they eventually explode.
Like they do all this stuff targeting,
oh my God.
But,
and some of them are still down there and there's some areas like we're
submarines can't go,
I imagine,
but I'm not an expert on that.
But you know,
I've read about all these,
all this equipment.
I mean it's,
it's cool stuff.
The landmines are crazy.
The idea that you're just going to go to war with anything that touches these
things and just blow them up like that.
That would be an ethical idea.
So now in order to make a more ethical,
they are trying to come up there.
There are lots of new landmines right that I've read about.
Like the self healing minefield is one of my favorites.
So it's a mind field where the landmines can,
can locomote a little bit.
So you spread them out and then if something comes through they basically set up
a local area network.
So each landmine kind of has like basically Wifi and they're talking to each
other so they kind of know where each other are at.
Then if some of them get blown up,
other ones are able to like hop and they just do these little hops until they
make the,
until the evenly distribute themselves again.
And so then you've got this,
what they call a self healing minefield,
but that's nothing compared to the crab mines.
The ones that are designed to be dropped off shore and they've got crab legs and
they scuttled up the a on the bottom of the ocean,
up to the,
uh,
up through the,
the beach basically,
and then on to land.
And that's how you mind,
like those walking mine or bombs from Mario brothers.
Exactly.
Another example of video games here,
dude,
don't want to get hit by a turtle shell.
What happens?
These crabs go in the water and they run up onto the beach.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's a good example of,
of what they call biomimetics.
So how big are they?
Well,
they're about the size of a,
of a crab.
I mean,
and I don't know if the,
I've seen a descriptions of that.
I don't,
I've never seen a real one of those.
And I don't think those are really in use.
But it's a great example of if you want to build a machine that's going to
operate in a certain environment,
you think of the environment as a problem,
right?
The problem is how do you locomote on the bottom of the ocean and the pounding
surf.
Uh,
how do you do that?
Well,
there are answers to all these problems.
They're animals,
right?
A lobster is the answer to that problem.
A crab is the answer to that problem.
And so you go and you study the animals and then,
uh,
you've baked take the basic principles about how they locomote and how they do
whatever,
and then you distill them down your stick them into a robot.
So no matter where you want to go,
there's usually a solution to that problem in the form of an animal
that you could study.
And I push up my glasses on to by dose.
She,
Jesus,
the idea that you could make like a million little robot mine crabs and just
unleash them on a beach.
That's like the third chapter of Robo pocalypse really?
Well,
hell yeah.
That's too cool not to put into a book.
Right?
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
I got this part where they're all walking across Boston,
like they're walking across this plaza and there's,
spoiler alert,
they sense vibration to their feet.
Right.
And so that whenever they sense the vibration,
they raised their little feet up in the air and that they all kind of do it at a
pet.
You know,
I don't know what's going to be in this movie,
but there are some things that,
God,
I just,
I just want to see it.
That's awesome man.
Wow.
I can't wait to read it.
When you wrote this,
was,
is this like something that was,
was in your head for a while before you wrote it?
Yeah,
man,
these are ideas that I've just been sort of percolating around for a really long
time.
My first book with how to survive a robot uprising,
I was just making fun of all the Hollywood bs where robots are killing,
you know,
I specifically made fun of like stuff I love like the Matrix and Terminator of
course,
they love it.
I'm thinking about it.
Right.
But,
uh,
then I tell you,
I kind of went to the dark side,
you know,
wrote that,
wrote that.
It's fiction,
you know,
science fiction,
killer robots.
There's sexy man.
They got biblical themes built in like they make for great drama.
Do you,
um,
look at the idea of uh,
technology and robots as like a life form that human beings are responsible for
igniting and starting in the world?
Marshall Mcluhan,
I think it was,
someone just told me this quote the other day,
it's brilliant quote.
He said that humans are the sex organs of machines.
Like,
isn't that a beautiful quote?
There's ways of looking it.
I see.
This is one
thing that as a roboticist you have to do this,
you have to look at a human being from a totally alien perspective,
right?
So like,
and I have a point,
but like if you look at it like how to do speech recognition or some or f or g
emotion recognition from a robot's perspective,
we are just moving pieces of flesh around on our faces and to different
configurations.
And then that conveys some sort of inner chemicals.
I mean,
it's not intuitive.
It's not easy to figure out.
And you can look at humankind as like all we do is we cover the earth in lawns.
We are slaves to grass,
right?
Like if it wasn't for us,
you know,
grasp wouldn't really exist everywhere that it does.
And so if you look at human beings from sort of these alien perspectives,
sometimes cool shit falls out.
And,
and some people do think that it's our destiny to create the next,
uh,
intelligent life form,
you know,
and to,
and to set it free.
And then those people usually think that it's our turn to retire mom's more
event.
He says,
you know,
once we do this,
children of the mind,
right?
Once we make the robots,
then,
then we're done.
We're finished.
Like we achieved our goal.
I disagree.
It's so terrifying.
But the idea that there's a reason why dinosaurs dinosaur isn't around anymore
because you know,
they,
they got wiped out.
Something better came along.
We like to think,
and it's called people now we're the new head of the planet,
but why would we think that we can hold the spot forever?
I mean it doesn't make any sense.
Well I think that we're going to evolve with our tools.
Are we going to become a part of a computer or we going to become a symbiotic
organism?
You know,
I just saw my,
I wrote a book about it.
It's called amped and it came out this year and it's basically,
yeah,
it's about thinking about like what happens when we start integrating this
technology into our own bodies and just on a,
not thinking about crazy science fiction far out stuff.
Just thinking about right now what's really cool about this to me is that the
people who are getting this are people that have real serious disabilities,
like two people who are willing to have a hole drilled in their skull and like a
neural implant placed on the surface of their brain to improve their quality of
life.
And it's not like Tony Stark,
you know,
or,
or like rich kids or you know,
getting a leg up in school or where it's like the most vulnerable challenged
people in our society are getting this technology and in and in some cases it's
making them,
it's not bringing them back to normal.
It's taken them past normal.
And so people with disabilities are like becoming people with super abilities
and that's a pretty cool trend to watch.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Cause I mean,
what's it going to be like when you realize that hey,
if you really do want to be the fastest sprinter on the planet,
you've got to cut your legs off because like there's just no way to do it.
Oh my God,
that hurts more being lucky enough to born.
You know why
that hurts?
Because I know someone's going to do it.
That's,
you know,
you think about,
you think about when you think someone's going to do it.
Armstrong and you know,
I dunno,
you mean Neil Armstrong?
No one on the moon
that lance got.
Well,
did you make that akin to hacking your legs off,
taking performance enhancing drugs?
Well,
I think that's a little bit,
a little bit crazy.
Oh,
there's a leap,
right?
I mean there's definitely a leap,
which is you got to go back to go forward,
right?
Like because without the,
without performance enhancing drugs,
you're,
you're still not like disabled.
Like Oscar Pistorius,
he competed in the London 2012 Olympics.
Right.
The guy who has no legs below the knees,
he ran alongside able bodied athletes on prosthetics,
like super advanced prosthetics.
If you take those prosthetics off of him,
he ain't going anywhere.
Right.
And that's a difference.
I mean,
if you,
if you take somebody off of performance enhancing drugs,
they're still capable of doing whatever it is that they were doing just slower
or not as well or,
or whatever.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an interesting thing,
the performance enhancing drug thing because by keeping it secret and by hiding
it in,
by sneaking around it,
what I mean,
it take all the moral arguments out of it when it comes to like cheating and you
know,
and achieving victory in unseemly methods,
most of you are willing to do that.
They think that they have to do it in order to compete.
They think there's hidden rules right in keeping with the hidden rules.
But I think it's also like really dishonest to the,
the actual,
um,
the issue becomes,
it's dis dishonest to the actual idea of human ability because human ability
under these incredibly enhanced conditions is quite a bit more than regular,
a regular person's ability.
So we have these distorted perceptions of like records that had been achieved
through,
you know,
through uh,
we just,
we,
we need to know,
I mean if,
if we're going to all this side that they're going to take looking for bedrock,
we want like that definition of human,
straight up,
natural human.
I want to compare myself to Babe Ruth and have that shit be,
you know,
a straight comparison.
It gets to be,
to be a weird situation when you've got a bunch of people introducing all these
alien things into the body and eventually it probably will be parts.
It probably will be.
That's why this is scaring me so much.
When you said that at some thinking to someone actually chopping their legs off
and giving themselves robot legs?
Well I,
you know,
I don't,
uh,
somebody would fucking do it and have you,
there's a cool book called machine man by Max very,
which I love any book that's from the written one of the,
from the perspective of like an autistic person because a person with aspergers,
you know,
the,
cause if you read books that are from those perspectives,
they tend to be really Hemingway ask like this short sentences,
they're easy to read.
I really liked him.
But anyway,
it was a book where that happens.
It's a good one machine man.
But do you think that it would be as simple as we would engineer
them so we could shut them off and that's how we can fill that gap?
Is that,
yeah.
Is it possible?
No,
I mean think about,
okay,
sure.
Think about that.
You shut them off.
I mean,
so if you have a robot that you know,
you don't shut an elevator off whenever it's got like 20 people on it,
it's a hundred stories up.
Like there,
there are circumstances where,
you know,
you have to have a,
what do they call it,
graceful failure or are graceful degradation or something where it needs to fail
gracefully.
It can't just fail all at once.
Um,
so if you shut it down,
it needs to shut down in stages so that it doesn't hurt people.
Um,
but yeah,
I think kill switches,
emergency stops,
those are a huge aspect of,
of building safe robots.
You know,
it's not the whole story.
It seems like the real issue would be how much of the human ideal of life would
we program into it?
If you were going to engineer a life form,
which essentially you would be able to do if you had a robot and you turn this
computer into some sort of a sentient being,
what,
what aspects of the human psyche would you engineer it to it?
Would you get an engineer into a sense of survival?
Would it be able to understand that that's illogical and override it?
And if it was,
you know,
that strong and if you gave it some autonomy or would it just go with it?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
the thing that's scary about this is there are,
there are an infinite number of mines that you could really create.
You could create totally alien minds that just meditate on,
on things that we could never comprehend.
You know,
you could create mines.
I'm freaking everybody out,
freaking out,
totally freaking me out.
I think there's some,
like there's some story I read where there's uh,
uh,
some,
well,
I wrote a,
actually I wrote a story where there was a,
basically a robot that was designed to,
to paint happy faces on things and then it goes nuts and runs a muck and it just
paints happy faces on everything and it ends up destroying the universe,
painting happy faces because that's the way it sees the world.
You know,
I think,
you know,
there are a lot of people who,
who think a lot about,
uh,
you know,
ray Kurtzweil for instances,
he's really obsessed with this idea that we're going to upload our brains into
machines.
Um,
and that we will basically have a machine that simulates every neuron in your
brain and then you'll live inside and you'll live forever inside the box.
Right.
Um,
that's a great example of,
of giving a human,
you know,
experience like a human life to,
uh,
to a machine so that it knows what things are like from our perspective.
So it knows you don't step on babies when you're walking across the room.
Like that innate nature that we have,
I think it's important that we do convey are our ethics to,
you know,
to the machines that we build so that they behave in a way that,
uh,
that allows us to coexist.
You know,
hopefully,
or we're done son.
It's one or
the other.
Cause if it's US versus them,
they're going to be able to figure shit out so quickly.
They're gonna be able to make better versions of themselves very quickly.
Yeah,
and that's the idea of the singularity,
right,
is that we just bears definition.
We create a machine that's smart enough to make itself smarter and then you kind
of have a runaway feedback and it gets smarter and smarter,
but,
but I don't think that that's something that is really going to happen anytime.
So isn't it a possibility?
Yeah,
I absolutely think so.
Why would you be confident and thinking that it's not going to happen?
Well,
because,
because we're,
it's sort of like if we were alive with Jules Verne and we were like discussing
like,
well what should,
what shape should the capsule be when we go to the moon?
You know?
It's like we're not close enough to solving that problem to have sorta make
informed decisions about how we should solve it.
You see what I mean?
I see what you're saying.
We're going to have other robots in our lives a lot sooner and those have more
immediate like problems to solve.
Ethical problems too.
Yeah,
like robot fucked Dawes man for sure.
For sure.
That's going to be an ethical issue.
That's going to be like a slavery time issue.
If you have like a really good form of intelligent life that you've created,
it's an artificial intelligence,
but it's,
and you have it as a sex slave.
See that the thing is fucked up man.
[inaudible] thing like the thing where they're smart enough to,
to for us to worry about all these ethical thing.
I think that's far away.
I think.
Thanks you.
No,
it's,
it's all about human beings man.
So for instance,
the real problem when you make a fuck doll is do you allow a person to uh,
what,
what happens to the people who interact with it?
So if you have a guy who goes home everyday and he beats the crap out of this
doll,
is that okay?
If you built the doll,
should the doll call the police or should the doll take it?
And your decision there as a roboticist,
as of scientist,
product designer,
whatever you are,
you're making it,
you're just,
you're designing an ethical interaction between your product and a human being.
And your decision can affect whether this guy,
uh,
hurts a real woman,
you know,
or,
or if you're building toys for children or really lifelike pets,
you know,
a kid sticks the fake dog into the microwave.
Like what happens,
you know,
because my gut feeling is,
is not okay.
Right?
Uh,
the,
the animal should react and,
and there's,
there's actually research on this.
My wife's a child psychologist and at,
at University of Washington,
she's at in Portland where I live,
but before she was at Udab and they have this research there where they
basically took,
let me see,
I can get this straight.
Cause it's kind of fascinating.
They take these kids and have them play tic TAC toe against a virtual head,
right?
It looks like a person.
And then they have a scientist walk in and in half of the experiments the
scientist says to the robot head,
uh,
hey,
that was a really dumb ass move.
You're stupid.
And then half the time the says nothing.
And the other half the time the robot says,
Hey,
it's not okay for you to talk to me like that.
And when they asked the kids later,
whether the,
the,
the virtual head,
you know,
deserve to be like treated with respect or whether it was smart,
they acid,
all these,
ask these kids all these questions.
If the robot demanded moral treatment,
then the kids thought that the robot deserved moral treatment.
If it didn't,
they thought it was okay to,
to abuse it.
And so it just,
it comes right back down to it.
When you build a robot,
you're building an ethical interaction.
Wow.
You can mess it up.
You know?
I feel like that's fast
meeting.
That's uh,
that's that.
Yeah.
You can't allow something to just be brutalized and to take like punishment and
to not,
you can't like make a person can make an artificial person
future.
Right.
Where people are falling around with like perfectly human,
like robots and they just abused there was beat the shit out of them.
And
that would very quickly warp,
I think the [inaudible] of all of humans that would create sociopaths because
yeah,
we acclimate to whatever around,
you know?
Yeah.
Especially if it's indistinguishable unless we're already robots and we don't
know it.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
What do you buy with the simulation theory thing?
Man,
do you ever give a wrap your head around that?
Ever fuck with that,
the no,
lay it on me.
Oh,
what's this new thing?
That's these and these are legitimate scientists but majoring this robot,
the idea of the Damn Matrix,
the idea that we're in some sort of a,
an incredible computer program and then it's so complicated and so well done
that it's indistinguishable from real life and that week and you we're
interacting with things but that the more they study string theory,
they're studying the,
the in the computations of string theory,
they keep finding this self correcting computer code.
I don't understand what that means,
but I understand it's a very specific type of computer code that we didn't even
figure out until like the early 20th century.
I think that they,
I think they said we figured it out in the forties or 50s or something like
that,
and if I remember correctly,
but the idea that this is in these,
the string theory equations that they're putting together,
I don't understand mathematics,
but what I think they're trying to say,
and it's like it says is there's an eerie code to all this.
It's not just like we don't know what the code is,
but we can see that there's some repeating patterns.
No,
no,
no.
It's the,
it's a very specific type of code and that's when they're studying the nature of
reality.
So the nature of reality and it's like one of its smallest measurable forms is
very obviously computer code seven
hike.
It doesn't,
it doesn't seem like,
it doesn't seem like if technology moves in the certain,
the direction it's gone right now,
if,
uh,
our computers
get more and more powerful or our CGI shit,
it's more and more believable.
We've got to keep moving until one day we reach a point where we can simulate
reality,
right?
It's going to happen.
And if it's really fucking good,
that's going to be just like this
dude is that,
trying to think running man was running is that,
that's whatever they recreate the fight,
you know,
computer models.
I mean before all that happens,
we're going to be able to,
I can't wait until the day when I can say,
all right television,
whatever you are now I want to watch like running man,
but I want instead of a Arnold,
you know,
I want Jeremy Renner and I want like no Megan Fox.
I want an all female cast of young kid.
And then you have to follow them with a reality show camera as well.
And to get them all maps together and make them live together.
Oh that's awesome.
It just maps their bodies onto it,
you know?
And that would be like the ultimate ironic one to watch because they do that in
the movie.
How long before we have our first robot action hero.
Wait,
so what do you mean by robot guy in the movies we can have,
yeah,
like a robot actor.
So that's like all Ryan O'neal's qualities with,
you know,
a little of Arnold Schwarzenegger's masculine bravado and you know,
Brad Pitt's acting chops or whatever,
you know,
and just mix it all up together and make it the perfect robot action here.
Pouty Lips.
My Lips are not about [inaudible] son of a bitch.
Get some chapstick and injections.
I just punch myself in the face myself.
Yeah,
I'm sorry all I'm sitting here thinking,
I'm just thinking of calculus from Futurama Calculus.
Sorry.
He's like that.
He's an actor,
a robot actor.
He's a robot actor.
Is that possible?
Could they ever make like a,
you know,
are we going to have human beings that are,
that ane distinguishable?
The question is like,
would you bother?
Because you could just create them and CG right and make them perfectly
realistic.
Would you bother creating the,
the real world version?
But I have to say I'm super excited because I have a short story that got picked
up by this director.
He's sort of a budding guy in London,
right?
But he's making a short film based on this thing and he's negotiating with a,
it's like a story about a guy in a robot boy that he lives with cause it's real
son has passed away and uh,
we got Lambert Wilson got the mirror of engine is going to be in this thing and
then he's working with a university to get an actual robot.
There's this thing called the Nao humanoid.
It's the size of an eight to 10 year old kid.
If you Google it,
I mean it moves like a real human being and they're going to have it as an
actor.
It's just a short film.
But I mean it's going to be pretty,
pretty cool.
It's going to be real robot acting
in a movie.
Oh God damn man.
I,
I saw that there was a very uh,
intricate Japanese robot.
It was a woman that was a,
have you seen that one?
It's very emotive.
And it was a woman.
Yeah,
it was just a head.
Okay.
Cause there's,
there's the actual Lloyd is that the NFL?
Is this it think not the one I was thinking [inaudible] there's a robot on the
screen,
folks that are listening to this on iTunes.
This,
this robot on the screen and it's walking around.
It's so weird.
That's not the one that God,
they're so good now.
I mean they really,
they really are like what we,
we hope robots would be when we were kids.
Remember lost in space.
That's stupid.
Fucking garbage can garbage can robot.
That was the dumbest looking robot ever.
Danger will Robinson.
Danger.
There's little like tyrannosaurus arms that were just out on arms like they
would clip and he had to do their bidding.
Always.
They love that robot is obsessed with that room.
What was that robot's name?
He was Robbie.
Robbie,
the robot willing space.
But he was in a lot of stuff.
He was um oh really?
Yeah.
And there were like different versions of him and he's always hard for me to pin
down in my head because he was around for a while.
But Brian pull up Robby the robot.
Let's see what that looks like.
I haven't looked at that one.
Kind of cool thing about robots I've noticed.
No,
that's Ravi and his friend Jeff.
Robin,
this is Robby the robot man.
It looks like,
we'll see that Brian.
Okay,
danger.
That's,
yeah,
he was actually pretty bad ass arms would just come out of the center of his
chest,
but he always had a lesson.
No matter what will Robinson,
we were like be like,
listen bitch,
we're going to go exploring.
He was like the first gay robot,
right?
No,
no,
no.
The other dude was the gay guy because that lost in space was a weird show.
They had a guy who liked,
acted really obviously gay.
Look at that.
That looks like a fucking disco floor.
But that was seriously,
that's,
those are gay robots.
What was the dude's name?
What was the dude's name that happens in price or something?
No,
no,
no.
How dare you?
So do you like this TV?
Oh,
I love,
that's to
your original loss of space was a crazy show,
man.
It was for 1965 to 1968 they would like land on planets and shit.
Well,
they were,
they were marooned.
It was like a Gilligan's island,
except they were on some tiny planet.
There have been some great ones.
I mean,
I always used to love small wonder when I was a kid,
you know,
picky.
The,
uh,
the robot who the dad is a roboticist and he brings her home to like test her
out and she sleeps in his son's closet.
Jonathan Harris was Dr. Zachary Smith.
Dot.
Zachary Smith was like the first,
like pretty obviously gay
character on television.
That might've just been all the SPANDEX unitards that they were wearing on that
show when he was,
he was at [inaudible].
He's very eccentric to the,
I mean in,
if it's really feminine,
apologize,
sobbing way.
He was a villain.
Right?
I mean,
he was always scheming back.
Well,
he's always dumped ruining things.
Stupid stupid Dr. Smith.
And he was like,
he's ego would always be his folly,
you know?
Yeah.
That was a great show,
man.
Well these,
they're really fun to watch today because it's like,
you know,
they thought this was going to be like 1990 like that's how we're going to be in
like living in colonies in space and so there's this sort of a idea of like man,
space travel never really materialized in a way.
A lot of people thought it was from the 1960s so you get this weird idea of what
they thought the future was going to be from these shows.
It's really fascinating.
I think they,
I think they actually misjudged human nature.
Like there's this idea that we've accomplished this amazing feat by going to the
moon,
right?
We planted a flag.
We've walked around like we went into the uncharted world depths,
the wilderness.
Like it's an amazing thing to do and you think that that sort of raw inspiring
event is going to propel mankind into the stars.
But actually we were just competing with the Russians and it was just,
it was enough to put a flag there and the instant that we need to go beyond that
I think is the instant that some other nation plants a flag next to ours or
knocks it down.
Flag on Mars.
Yeah.
I mean it's all about just like pissing on a,
on trees,
you know,
it's the trees just keep getting further away from Earth.
Well it's also to let you know like look,
if we can go to the moon,
we can launch missiles on you had from space still my lecture notes and let you
know,
let you know how we run and shit from orbit bitch.
Yes we can.
I mean if you to be the first person to set up a base on the moon would be an
incredible military advantage and he's going to do it.
I think it's going to,
it's going to be a great thing because it's going to excite those dude Madge and
if we actually start having bases on the moon,
if people actually started doing that,
if they develop the technology to one day have bases on the moon and we would go
there like going to fucking Hawaii.
It's like a 24 hour trip and the shuttle,
I totally believe that because I mean it's like something tragic is going to
happen.
Like you know like a,
like a lot of the land's going to be poisoned or something.
It'll be like fucked band.
They would have to tear a forum on the moon because the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere that ain't going to happen.
Could do that someday.
That's,
that's the whole premise of Promethean us was that they were terraforming that
planet.
They were trying to make it habitable for their life form if they're going to be
able to do that for sure.
One day people always argue that we're going to screw earth up so bad that then
we're going to have to go to Mars,
the moon and the like.
The,
the resource expenditure took leave earth with a lot of people and even just to
go to the moon,
much less Mars is so out of whack.
I mean,
you'd be better off like almost doing anything to fix the earth.
They're just eking it out here.
I mean,
let's face it,
if you poison the earth's atmosphere so that you can't even walk outside
anymore,
or you screw up the atmospherics is that we're getting radiation from,
well guess what?
That's Mars.
Why go to Mars to build
dome,
right?
Just build a dominant Arizona.
Right?
Everything has to go to Mars for no shit.
Fix this stupid.
So I don't,
I've always thought that was bullshit.
The idea that we're going to mess up her so bad,
we'd have to go to Mars,
but the only way I could think we could do that though,
it's like nuclear shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's a massive nuclear holocaust all across the country,
across the world.
We all launched bombs at each other and just wipe out that they would make so
many areas radioactive that would almost be like,
you can't live here anymore.
You know,
that would still be pretty tough to do I think,
just because like really?
Yeah,
because you'd have to launch all of them at the exact same time.
Right.
And then they have to land all over the year.
I mean,
if you think about when we first got nukes,
we were doing crazy shit.
We were launching them all the time and space ground the water on the show.
We showed a video of all the nuclear explosions from 1947.
It's online,
you can get it.
Uh,
it's on,
uh,
I forget the website,
but it shows the first tests and then it shows Hiroshima and Nagasaki and it
shows all these different ones that they did in Nevada,
Nevada.
It's crazy.
Oh Dude.
They were nuking the shit out of everything.
So my favorite is project ploughshares.
Okay.
This is like Iowa or something.
And here's the notion.
We're gonna mine for natural gas.
Uh,
there's,
the gas is trapped in all these facts now we run water through,
it's called fracking.
Right?
But they're like,
we're going to free up all this natural gas and harvest it by detonating a nuke
under the ground.
So they drill this giant hole,
they drill this giant hole,
they put a nuke at the bottom of it,
they fill the hole up and then they detonate the nuke.
Here's what happens.
Highly irradiated,
natural gas shoots out of this chimney.
It ejects all the,
all the crap they put in there,
it goes into the atmosphere.
All of the natural gas is,
is poisonous.
It's like,
you know,
it's got radiation and it,
and,
and they're like,
oh,
well that's not a good idea.
So much for certain turning swords to plowshares.
Right.
Like did they do this?
Uh,
this is like,
this is not that long ago.
I would say in the middle of the 20th century,
but I don't know for sure.
Oh,
here's why.
I know that.
What is the,
what does the,
do you know what the name of the operations called?
I think it was called project ploughshares.
Project pro.
Yeah.
Look it up.
Um,
the,
the reason I like it is because I was thinking,
and this is a little bit of a spoiler,
but while I was writing bro Apocalypse,
I was thinking,
look,
if I was a superintelligent AI,
right,
I'm not going to hang out and have all my processors like in a place where
humans are going to be comfortable,
right?
So what's my fortress of solitude?
Right?
So when these nukes detonate,
they vaporize a spiritual chunk of like rock underground or they create this
chamber and the walls turned to glass,
right?
So it's this bubble deep under the ground,
highly radioactive.
It is the ultimate fortress of solitude.
And it's of course where my bad guy lives.
Sorry,
I kind of blew that.
I want to read that again.
That is a dope idea that we would create a place with a bad guy lives because
we're so stupid.
We blew up nukes and a hole that we dug into the ground.
You know,
it's always,
it's what was the Hubris,
you know,
all the Hubris dance,
insanity.
I can't even believe that.
No.
Is that a case of people just having too much power?
Because it's a military project to do whatever they want to do.
And the scientists are allowed to say,
hey,
let's try this.
Like some wacky scientist
may not be popular viewpoint,
but I think it's awesome.
I think it's optimism.
I think it's like human,
the human race as a little kid who has come stumbled across like this awesome
new toy and they're like,
what can we do with it?
Oh,
let's try everything.
You know,
because like in the fifties,
we had used technology to end World War II.
People were high on technology.
They were like,
man,
technology is going to do everything for us.
Like,
we're going to eat it.
It's going to be food pills.
We're not even going to have to eat this bullshit that earth creates for us.
Come full circle.
Now it's all about organic and we're afraid of chemicals and afraid of
technology.
But you know,
in the fifties that was like the golden age.
It was like,
we're gonna have atomic pens.
You know,
I don't know why we need atomic energy and our pens,
but dammit we're going to have it.
And,
uh,
I wrote a book called where's My jet pack that,
covers all this stuff?
I'm sorry,
I keep dropping all these books.
Do your book sounds fucking awesome now.
Right.
I even had a joke about that.
You'll never have like weed and jet packs together at the same time.
It needs created human torpedoes.
Yeah.
That's,
that's what happens.
Plus no one would work because why would you show up at work when you could
smoke pot and fly?
Like they'd be very,
very few things that you would be having more fun at smoking pot and flying
around it.
Right?
Or would we just be in a future where Louis C K stands in from an audience?
It says,
why does anybody complaining about jet packs lying people?
You know,
that would definitely happen.
I mean,
we would just so sick of it.
Oh,
fucking jet packs.
I've always got bugs in my teeth.
It's hard to getting my natural girls to fill my jet pack.
You know,
why can't we make a fucking solar?
Jetpack is 2037 Whoa.
Always complain for sure.
But that's why things get better.
Exactly.
It's really important,
you gotta be able to silence even the most bitter of critics.
And there's certain things to do.
A bad ass jet pack I think would be,
that can actually have a compact,
sort of a light backpack sorta sides thing they can fly around with.
So I,
I can,
I can give you the low down on the,
on the jet pack because they're,
you know,
I remember all this,
right?
So,
uh,
forties Wendell Moore got a grant from the army to build a jetpack.
And so he's working for bell aerosystems.
This is a guy who specialize in building small rocket engines,
basically airplanes that are flying really,
really high.
There's not a lot of atmosphere so they can't play in off of it.
So in order to change direction,
they fire these little rockets,
you know,
like that.
It's like a spacecraft type deal.
So we took one of these little rockets and you literally strapped it onto his
back and tethered himself to the ground and just turned it on.
And Eh,
he broke his knee.
He shattered his knee actually immediately,
but it worked.
So then he literally hired the kid who mowed his lawn,
a guy named bill suitor to who was like 19 Hale and hearty,
you know,
to,
uh,
to test the jet pack.
And,
and they,
they had a working model of the jet pack,
you know,
it's called a rocket belt.
You know,
it's literally a rocket,
you know,
and that's the problem is that you just take the hydrogen peroxide and silver or
whatever,
you put them together and then it creates an explosion and the real hard thing
is to throttle it so you don't just explode.
And then it runs out.
It runs out of juice in like 30 seconds.
And I,
you know,
it's got a terrible fuel to weight rate and that's the problem.
You know,
they,
they literally,
they put a buzzer in the helmet because they test,
they showed that,
you know,
Bill Sutor would,
would take these things to the Olympics.
They were in like that bond movie.
Like they would do this for demonstrations to make money.
Uh,
after the program was scrapped and a,
they put a buzzer in the helmet that would buzz after 20 seconds basically
saying you better land right now you've got 10 seconds before you just turn into
a,
you know,
a ballast.
Yeah,
I,
I was at a Wpbi my friend willy has a,
a radio show there and they did this thing in the parking lot where a dude fluid
jet pack and we've got a video of it.
He,
what did he throw it?
We were there.
We were you there for that one.
He flew it for like 30 seconds.
I think that's like all it had.
You can only do it for like a minute.
So he got it up to a minute or something.
But it's,
it's pretty crazy.
But this guy's fucked his legs up.
His,
both of his knees are blown out from doing this,
like as ACL is are gone.
So he's all fucked up from just crashing with this thing.
The thing he got w would have to worry about is anything that has enough power
to get you to be flying in the air has enough power to speed you into something.
People who can be smacking into each other,
we would have to have,
we would have,
there would be no way they would let you just have a jet pack.
You would have to have some sort of a like,
like a bumper car,
outer shell.
We'll see,
man.
See that's like,
I think that's a great example of applying a current mindset to a technology
that's in the future.
If they were really gonna make it,
there's no way to make it safe.
It would have to be controlled by a,
by a robot.
Basically.
Autonomous cars.
Those Google cars,
cars are essentially driving around now.
Yeah,
they,
a lot
of people are in a Seattle.
We're talking about how they see them all the time on the freeway.
Just driving around like a guy in the backseat and no one in the front seat.
She's a,
what the fuck is that like for that dude in the back seat is caused by hitting
the bikers and shit and knows when to change lanes.
I got into one of those at Carnegie Mellon where I went to school and I got into
their autonomous car,
drove with it in the backseat while it was driving,
going around,
uh,
like a test track.
Right.
And it was okay.
First of all,
the,
the wheel is turning by itself,
right?
And you're in the back.
So that's weird,
right?
But then it starts to kind of feel like,
uh,
I mean it doesn't wreck immediately.
And so you sort of start to loosen up a little bit and you,
you get the feeling that you're like on a ride,
you know,
like,
and you start to trust it.
Like when you're on a rollercoaster,
you know,
the ones driving it,
you just feel,
you feel like you're safe.
But then what happens is I started realizing this car,
it didn't know I was inside it.
Right?
So it's tolerant.
The tolerances for a car with nobody inside of it are very different than the
tolerances on a car.
Wow.
It would like hit the,
it would sort of sense that there was something there that wasn't,
you know,
and it would kind of swerve and it was throw you around like really hard and you
realize it doesn't give a shit.
Like it isn't going to be like doing the mom thing where it throws the handout
in front of you.
Like,
oh sorry.
Do you know this thing is just driving to the tolerance of the engineering that
it's designed for and you were just being thrown around in the back and this was
the car losing traction at any point.
You know,
if it was always safe,
it was seeing how fast it could go because they're competitive.
The Darpa Grand Challenge,
the Darpa urban challenge,
they had to go as fast as they could and they didn't have a human in them at
all.
So I was scared.
So now Google is different.
You know,
Google just bought Stanford's team essentially.
There's a guy named Sebastian Thrun who got me into school at Cmu.
And then he worked on the autonomous cars at Stanford because Stanford bottom
and then googled bought,
they took Sebastian and now,
I mean this Guy Sebastian Thrun,
he's going to change the world.
He's going to introduce autonomous vehicles.
It's an a change our cities.
It's going to save lives.
It's really cool.
I'm really proud of it.
That's awesome man.
That's amazing.
So do you think that's the future that everyone will have their own personal
autonomous vehicle and though I get in,
they'll just,
we'll,
we'll cue in on the highways and whatever and you're,
you'll be able to like read the newspaper and you're little vehicle.
We'll just,
he won't be in control of it anymore.
Well,
the first thing,
I'm not sure if people are really doing this where they're in the back outside
of a closed course because um,
these cars require a person to be behind the wheel to take the blame if it
wreck.
Oh,
I see.
So you're just sort of like a big meaty blame
piece of blame machinery.
Like,
that's the only flower you play in the,
in this whole thing that's going to be
a job in the future though,
like a fry guy.
But you're going to be sitting in the backseat of a car being the blame blame
guy and amped amped.
There is a truck driver who all he does is he sits in the front seat and he's
just there to take the blame.
That's his whole job.
Wow.
And he just drives cross country 24,
seven in these,
in these trucks,
it will be a job.
You know,
there will be a time where the are,
do these robot machine just moving back and forth across the country carrying
goods.
Yeah.
And you think about it,
it's like what is it that you can't put into the car and it's,
it's morality,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
And he asked to make certain decisions like what do you do if a horse is in
front of you?
Yeah.
Do you hit it?
Do we,
yeah.
Or do you slam on the brakes and risk losing control of the vehicle or do you
fuck it or do you just want to slow down,
put your arm outside the window and say hey,
hey what you doing?
Yeah,
like people have said that about,
I'm about small animals that like if you see a squirrel and you should just hit
them because if you swerve like the people die all the time from swerving to get
away from squirrels.
Maybe carriage.
Yeah it's a different side.
That's a really interesting point.
This is what got will Smith.
I'll uptight and I robot right where at the end the big reveal for his character
as he's like,
oh robust saved my life from a car but it let the little girl next to me die
because the probability of saving her life was lower and it's like how are you
going to blame the robot for that?
That's like saying I put my finger in a pencil sharpener and it cut me.
That's what it's designed to do.
What are you not going to hate the pencil sharpener.
I mean well you are for a movie though.
Cause the middle of America,
none are going to understand.
I was bumping.
That happened robust digging that movie and then I was like,
oh that's weak.
The CGI in that movie was dope.
Yeah,
I know what crack Capsid,
amazing work.
All those robots go nuts.
Right?
And what do they do?
What do they do?
They turn red,
they got re,
you know there's that part where the robot is like a,
it was an old lady like in her house,
you know,
and she's like,
okay,
well can you make me some toast or something?
Right in.
The robot turns around and it's glowing,
bright red.
And I'm like,
what?
A thoughtful roboticist to include a red led in there just in case they all turn
evil to indicate to people,
oh your robot has flipped over and the evil mode,
you're going to want to plan accordingly to grow a robots of scary robots would
beat the shit out of you.
Those robots in that moving,
if that was,
there was a whole bunch of them and they had their own thoughts and ideas.
I think that's very possible.
Now those,
those robots are bullshit.
So what scares the shit out of me?
How can you say there were bullshit?
Because if you're making a domestic robot that's going to operate in people's
homes,
right?
It's going to be in people's homes,
old people,
young people.
It's going to be on the street walking dogs.
I mean,
I thought that was awesome,
right?
Here's the deal.
You're going to want to make a safe robot.
It's a safe consumer product.
Okay,
so just think of this even just from the beginning for like one second from the
perspective of a person who's actually building a humanoid robot to
sell,
okay?
First of all,
you know that a human being,
anything you put in their environment at home,
they are going to put their fingers in it.
They're going to try to have sex with it.
They're going to get in the bathtub with it.
They're going to find a way to like kill themselves.
Using this toaster is really hard to build safe.
Think about building this domestic robot.
I think the first thing that you're going to do is you're going to make it
incapable of hurting people.
You're going to make it small and light so that it can't walk through a plate
glass window so that if it loses its batteries and like goes all George Bush
segway and just falls over like then it won't like crush your baby.
Did that,
was that what happened to George Bush?
He was on one of those segways in the battery died.
Yeah.
Either that or it wasn't even on and he's,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not sure what was going through his head,
but he tried to mount up and there it just wasn't happening.
Oh No.
Um,
well those things need to be on.
They have a gyroscope that keeps,
yeah.
So,
but anyway,
I mean,
so,
so the point,
the point I'm trying to make is if you're going to build a real domestic robots
and someone's house is not going to be capable of crushing your fist with his
hand or leaping through a glass window and falling three stories and denting
the,
the concrete,
what the fuck?
What a fucking waste of money,
right?
First of all,
what if it's like how cars are today?
Like,
if you buy like say a brand new Mustang,
like a Ford Mustang Gt,
in the old days they used to have like 300 horsepower.
They weren't that fast.
Like the new ones,
just the standard Mustang Gt.
You can get there over 400 horsepower.
They're insanely fast for this.
Like I think it's like $30,000 or $35,000 or something like that.
That is insane amounts of performance compared to what existed in the 1960s if
the robot's keep getting better and better,
people are going to want to have like a Ferrari or a Cottey robot.
Well that's true.
So,
so people that are willing to lay down a premium,
and in fact I got to get Carl wrench made this short film called the gift and
these people have this snooty looking Butler robot that has a total bad ass,
totally physically over engineered for the job he does.
And it's an awesome,
awesome little film.
But um,
and then they gave him 47 Ronin.
I read this comic book when I was a kid when I was a kid.
I was super into like those black and white,
like really cool comic books,
like the creepy and Eerie series of your scene illustrated stuff.
Well the cro is kind of,
yeah,
sort of.
It's straight up black.
And this,
um,
there,
there was like all these compilation ones creeping Erie where all these like
different stories.
And I remember one of them from one of those types of comic books was about a
robot that wound up fucking this dude's wife.
And it was really heavy duty man because the guy tried to fight the robot and
the robot snapped his arm and broken front of them and the robot had this giant
Dick dominated.
It just don't,
yeah,
it was creepy
because it was like this guy couldn't do anything about it and this robot was
taking over and fucking his wife.
It was,
it was a really fucked up video cause our comic book rather.
Cause I remember reading it when I was like,
God,
I couldn't have been more than like eight or nine,
you know,
that's when I was like really into comic books.
That was my,
my comic book era.
And so,
uh,
this,
this image of this bald giant robot with this giant cock snapping this guy's arm
after he got done fucking his wife was like so disturbing.
I was like,
could you imagine if that's what you have to deal with?
It's just robot start coming along and fucking people's wives and snapping dudes
arms and shit.
I think that's kind of the underlying fear,
right?
Of course going to be better at us and everything.
And they're black robots.
Can we get a yeah,
we get some of that mixed in.
Yeah.
At least it wasn't fucking him.
Well that was probably next episode two,
fuck him with his own broken arm.
Pull that thing off and stuff it up his ass.
Literally.
It could do that.
That's some scary shit,
man.
Weirds for me to think about is that,
you know,
we know that you can't beat a robot at chess.
I mean,
we can't,
maybe you could if you were like a master,
right?
You can't be a robot at jeopardy.
It will.
Everybody's asked,
you know that you can't beat them on the battlefield.
Like robots have dominated a lot of different areas.
Like since we've been kids and we at least remember a time when you could beat a
robot at chess and just be a normal person who likes to play chess every now and
the next generations.
They don't,
they've never lived in a time when a robot didn't dominate them.
Add a lot of intellectual tasks and increasingly physical tasks.
Like there's going to be people born that don't remember a time when cars didn't
drive themselves better than humans can drive cars.
And it's interesting to think like,
well how about the fact that right now we have people that have never known a
life without the Internet?
Yeah.
Or being able to look things up on smart.
It's crazy.
I wanted to know what I would be like if I was one of these peak kids.
You know what I mean?
Very,
very early though.
But as far as like most people,
you were tuned into the Internet when you and your,
your twenties right?
Uh,
well,
I mean we had computers growing up.
It was more like the Internet was probably 18 but I've had computers.
What do you think,
like coming from like Ohio,
coming from a place like Columbus,
what do you think is like the biggest impact that the internet has to a place
like that?
Because now when you go back there,
do you find these kids to be like more tuned in and you were,
when you were there any,
it's definitely a communication.
Like back in the day,
the only way I would know anybody from another school or whatever is if I've met
them mad a game or if I went to a roller skating rink and they were in the men's
bathroom and they told me to come in and stall the fuck what happened there.
Now I think it's
like a death squad,
Ohio and we'll use it.
And Death Squad,
there was like a group of like a huge group of people that are all friends now,
right?
Good friends.
They're staying at each other's houses there,
you know,
flying in and getting each other at the airport and they're a gang now.
Right?
And that's all because of,
uh,
the Internet,
all the Internet connecting all these different things in a way that's never
happened before,
allows all these areas like in the,
you just have no culture coming into them.
It allows them to experience an incredible variety of different things right out
of their fucking computer.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's on specific details,
like really specific things that you're into.
We wouldn't be able to get a critical mass of people that were into it.
Like co locate.
Yeah.
I'll give you a big foot on a try.
If you were a big [inaudible],
you live in any fucking town who try finding a fellow bigfoot hunter.
That shit is hard,
man.
You can't,
you know,
order a cup of coffee.
And then,
so,
uh,
what do you guys think about bigfoot?
You know,
no one's going to talk to you about on the Internet for five minutes.
You get your own show.
Had a foot fetish,
guys trying to come to your house if you go.
Yeah,
right.
I've had guys,
I've had guys offer to massage my feet.
Are you a big foot lover too?
Wait a minute.
No,
no,
no.
Sasquatch,
Sasquatch.
That's what they call me,
honey.
Yeah,
the,
it's really tough to be a big foot person out there in the real world.
But on the Internet it's easy as fuck you just join a forum everybody.
Shit cause this is like got a new big foot video every couple of weeks nowadays
on the other end of that spectrum though,
don't you think it also started cheapens your relationships because like how's
that?
Well so you can't have like you can,
I don't know about other people,
maybe I'm just a Dweeb but I can maintain about two good friends but like real
buddies and then like anything beyond that is really,
there's a very narrow stripe of like acquaintances and then it's all,
you know,
you have all this time that you spend interacting with people online and it's a
thousand people.
And so you know,
and not to assign any value judgment to it,
it's a different type of interaction than like intense,
full bandwidth.
One on one talking to somebody.
Right.
But the advantage is that you get,
it's one to a thousand you know,
you get to interact with like 909 nine more people.
It's not as intense as just one to one but you have a bigger,
it's like more breadth and less depth is what I'm saying.
You know?
That's interesting.
I think it's also something that we're,
we have to get used to managing the managing the amount of information that
comes into your,
into your life and managing the amount of people that you're interacting with.
It can,
it can just any sort of social interaction through a message board or Facebook
or Twitter can,
you could get so absorbed in communicating with all these different people that
you,
you will never get anything done and you'll your,
you know,
your,
it will eat up all your time.
Yeah.
And you'll be the guy looking at his damn vibrating monster cell phones all the
time while you're out and your friends are just like,
I hate this guy
immersion.
This human merged into technology.
The,
it disturbs
me the most when I seen people that are really,
really addicted into role playing games.
That's where I see like,
like wow,
that's,
you could really get stuck in a black hole and lose your fucking life if you
ever met anybody.
That's a clone of anybody.
I have friends that are super into role playing games but also board games he
will get into.
But then also video games make,
make role playing games so much easier,
especially the massively online multiplayer stuff.
And a lot of times that's seems to me to be just simple escape.
Like you're just,
your life sucks or,
or it doesn't suck,
but it's just more fun.
It's way cooler than here.
And I had chicken shit going out and getting gold and bitches.
Anyone in real life,
you're smelling cat piss in your house.
Fuck is that smell?
Why is my beautiful couch cat piss smell?
I've seen this one toilet,
horrible shit online about parents who are neglecting their children because
there were just completely absorbed in these online goes.
My wife's a child psychologist.
She had a kid who is addicted to uh,
you know,
one of the online games and in order to deal with him,
she had to find his guild master who is some,
like this is a kid who was like 13 or 14.
She found his guild master who's like a,
like a 30 year old dude,
you know,
like in Eugene or something.
He comes up to Portland for a meeting and says,
hey man,
like,
you know,
you've got a problem and I'm going to have to limit the amount of raids you can
go on.
And,
and she had to,
but she had to make that human element real,
you know,
cause this kid had a real relationship with his guilt master.
They,
they'd hung out for hours and hours and hours.
You know,
they were tight but they never met,
you know,
and so they weren't able to,
she had to bring them in to look out for this kid.
Wow.
Did you see aligns with the new call of duty game last night?
Oh Man.
Jesus Christ.
There was people there at one in the afternoon,
outside of a game stop.
Just like sitting in these lawn chairs and I'm like,
what?
Who are these people?
Savages.
And then last night I was on sunset,
four blocks of just straight mob people waiting in line for a video game.
And I'm like,
what the,
I don't get that because like I woke up this morning and it was on my front
porch.
Thanks Amazon.
You guys have like,
what?
Oh,
you got an extra seven hours or something.
Well,
yeah,
you're not an addict though.
The community,
right.
They're there to chill out.
That's true.
Yeah.
Totally.
Look,
that's a fucking fun game.
That game scares the shit out of me.
Oh,
that's great.
I've watched Bruce buffer plays that he plays it at the airport and I was like,
you gotta keep that fucking game away from me.
I will lose my life.
I'll have no life.
Forbes article about a guy named Peter Singer who's a,
like a,
uh,
basically a consultant for anybody.
The CIA,
like all,
all the military infrastructure and they had him design all the like robotic
weaponry that's in the new call of duty and a shit is all like super legit.
Really realistic.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Those gains so immersive gotta have like 12 year old reflexes.
It's like,
I'm not going to go out and try to start a career as a gymnast,
you know?
Right now,
too old.
That's the way I feel about call of duty.
I can't,
oh,
you would just have to get absorbed.
You was just a really terrible
first started out at quake,
but I got really good after a while I was,
that was my addictive
castle hill often Stein man,
that was old school.
That was like the first one,
right?
The first wasn't that the first and it didn't,
it wasn't,
you couldn't jump or anything.
It was flat know.
Well there was Duke Nukem
well,
first time was the first and then came doom.
Doom.
Right,
right,
right.
And Doom.
They named doom,
uh,
from that line in the color of money with Tom Cruise or a Tom cruise went out to
play.
This guy at Tom Cruise is like the best player in the country.
And he had this crazy pool cue and the guy said,
which guy in the case?
Boy.
And he goes in here and he opens it up and he goes doom.
And the idea was that their game was so bad ass that that's what they're going
to do.
The whole video game ministry,
we were going to,
we're going to like drop some doom on them.
They did all was the 90s,
it was all articles about those guys like buying shitloads of Ferrari's.
I know car Mac man have been over his um,
studios a few times of that.
I,
those guys are really cool guys.
And Carmack is like a real rocket scientist like in his
bear time is that these guys are all really,
really smart.
Yeah,
he's dude,
he's beyond spark.
He's one of those guys where I talked to him and I'm like,
I'm not convinced we're the same species.
I'm not convinced at this guy.
He's so,
he's so,
so past talk,
you know like just computer wise what he's doing all day,
you know,
the computations that he's making,
the way he's redesigning these first person shooters.
He's,
he's like a super,
super fucking genius
having lived in Seattle.
Ha.
Like you see you,
you meet these guys,
right?
The ones that have started companies and are like Madden and like the,
and for me they're always,
it seems like about five or 10 years older than me and I'm always pissed.
I'm always like,
damn,
if I was 10 years older,
like I would been on that scene of it.
I had a chance to like go nuts with it.
Like they have like I have a buddy who works for Bungee,
right?
He,
he,
he makes halo.
I mean it's a sweet job but when he was in college,
he wrote a textbook on how the program graphics and you know what that got him a
job at Bungie but it didn't get him of a Ferrari garage.
Like didn't get him.
Like every generation has these smart guys,
but whenever they have an girls and when they fall in,
you know,
it's all about how,
how much the field's been blown open.
Like there's a lot of stuff like low hanging fruit waiting on you.
Of course he probably bust my ass if you heard me say this and be like,
I earned it trivializes my accomplishment.
He certainly did innovate in a big way in the first person shooter world.
Yeah.
It was um,
him and there was another guy that was on with him with
doom and then that guy left when he made quake.
Who Guy was,
he had long hair.
It's fabulous hair.
He's a,
yeah,
he was a very controversial video game designer himself.
And those are those,
those are the original it guys.
But they went on to make quake quake two quick three.
Each one of them got better and more intense with the graphics.
And it's like that,
just the amount of hours of entertainment they provided with those video games.
It's like,
it's staggering.
And this call of duty is on that.
That's the next level shit that's like the highest level.
What I love is it puts Hollywood to shave.
Like movies don't make this much money like movies or just pay.
They pale in comparison now to video games and way more exciting.
And so you're,
you get so locked in on one of those fucking games and you're creeping around
shooting at people understand why video,
why movies aren't lost leaders to video games.
Now it's almost,
it's always like,
yeah,
we're making a movie.
Oh,
and we're going to have a video game.
It's like,
dude,
the money is in video games.
Make a movie just to get as it like a PR campaign to get people into your video
game because that's where the cash money is.
That is,
yeah.
Not a bad idea.
Especially if you develop like one of these call of duty type franchises where
it just becomes,
everyone plays it.
Ice Tea is always on TV plan.
Doesn't he play that?
He plays gears of war two.
Right.
You know what I did?
I was on wards and other ones not being Nintendo dude.
I got to,
I went to the thrift store and I bought it like an old old school and an old
VCR.
Whoa.
You know what I found like watching old school movies on a VCR and an on a
little bitty four by three like TV,
you know,
the graphics weren't as good,
right?
They didn't have CGI and all that stuff.
Like I'm thinking like,
uh,
lost boys and like terminator two and stuff.
Ready.
Good graphics,
but not the,
you watch it on that little screen.
It's convincing.
It's really low resolution.
Like there's a lot of stuff that you did.
It just come goes right by.
Well,
have you ever seen an old movie that's been brought to Blu Ray?
Uh,
yeah.
I think I can't.
Aliens.
The second alien movie was blocked,
brought to Blueray.
And when you watch it on a modern television with a blue ray player,
it's so hokey.
Look in the fucking background.
There's a scene where there's a,
a,
a jet that's parked there or one of those,
whatever those ships,
spaceships.
And then the background is supposed to be like this whole warehouse area.
It's so fucking fake.
I mean,
it's so obviously painted.
It looks terrible.
I mean,
it looks so bad.
It's so hokey.
Like,
oh my God.
Like you're not supposed to have this at this resolution.
When the director made it,
he made it for a certain resolution.
That's when you deal with special effects.
You've got to respect that.
You can't pump it up to blue ray.
Greedy bitches.
You know why I bought the Nintendo was but I have a daughter.
She's two and a half right,
and she is not allowed in the room when I'm playing video games because it's
intense.
Like I'm playing Skyrim and it's like very rare to skyram.
What is Skyram?
I'm sorry,
of life.
I had
to run away from the video game Smith.
It's basically junkie.
It's in the oblivion series.
It's a,
it's one of those role playing games,
but it's single player so you can finish it and you can leave your life,
but it's incredibly rude.
You're playing against the computer in our playing on my,
in a total immersive world,
I mean I can talk about Skyrim forever.
You're running it through your PC or bought a new gaming PC four to run this
game for a while.
It was more fun to actually download all the mods to like hype up all the,
all the texture mapping,
all the water,
the fire,
the blood,
that atmosphere,
the weather.
And what are you doing?
Like you fighting people in this game?
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's your typical Lord of the rings rip off.
Like you're in a world where,
you know,
it's like that medieval stuff.
There's magic and all that.
It's really,
really fun.
But it's intense.
And if I was playing it,
my two year old,
no way is she allowed in the room.
Right.
And so one day she says to me something along the lines of like,
you know,
video games are scary.
And I'm like,
that's bullshit man.
Video Games,
Super Mario Brothers is not scary.
Right.
So I,
that's why I bought the Nintendo.
I showed her this,
I was like,
this is a video game,
honey.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Just so that she's not like terrified by what video games have sort of become,
you know.
Well.
Yeah,
especially if you're watching a man's or a young man's,
you know,
something that's geared towards them.
I mean obviously it's dead.
I guess there's a few women that want to go run around playing call of duty.
It must be,
I mean it's so popular.
It must be women playing it as well,
right?
There's tons of but are there games that are geared specifically towards women?
Someone's going to be waiting outside to kick you in the balls.
Like if you keep down this road of questioning whether women are are playing
these games because I mean they are,
they are in a big way,
right?
I'm just guessing.
I don't know the community,
I'm no,
there was a lot of women quake players though.
There was like a lot of girls that were really good.
They would play doubles with dudes and fuck them up and it was embarrassing.
It's shit cause you just get checked and quake by a check because have you seen
the zombies and the new call of duty?
They have a zombie mode.
Like it's crazy as fuck.
Yeah.
I hope you guys enjoy it.
I say,
here's,
here's a,
just shows you a little bit of the zombies.
It's from Mashimo.
This is like the trailer.
We're looking at a trailer right now.
I'm getting really scared.
You guys.
Wow.
Graphics are amazing.
Yeah.
Just like what they can do now in a vid just to,
to CGI.
Opening for a video game is incredible.
This is like really dingy.
I love that.
This is like post apocalyptic bus scenario.
It's probably generated by the game engine,
you know?
Wow.
Oh,
this is great.
Other soldiers.
Yeah.
Is there anything more fun than shooting zombies
that is a negatory
over.
Yeah,
right.
I had a Zombie dream last night.
Man.
Walking dead gets me dreaming about zombies all the damn time now and they just
hoard you and you're pretty much just like constantly having to try to get the
fuck away from these zombies.
Isn't it funny that one of the most fearsome things that we can conjure up is a
human being that's dead and wants to get you.
It's not,
robots are kind of similar,
right?
I mean it's the,
we're afraid of the human form format.
Well,
we're afraid of
human form in,
in a diseased manner to whether it's psychologically diseased or whether it's at
28 days later,
that epidemic,
that rage shit that got out,
that was one of the scariest movies ever.
I got a whole horror movie theory about this.
My theory is that the reason that like a werewolf is scarier than like a wolf is
because the werewolf,
because it has human traits,
has the capability of being evil,
right?
Because a wolf or like an animal or just nature is not good or evil.
Like you don't blame the wolf for,
for killing somebody.
It's like that's what a wolf does,
but as soon as you inject some human into it,
then you have something that's capable of just really being evil and just doing
something for evil's sake.
Yeah.
That's,
I think that's a really accurate representation.
If you'd stop and think about it,
it's very rare that a wolf would actually,
I have a friend and how they think about this,
when people have a friend who,
uh,
had these Wolfe's,
they were,
um,
his pets and they were like seven eighths Timberwolf and they had like a little
bit of Husky or something else.
And I'm in,
they were essentially Wolf's man and he didn't really have good control over
these things.
And they got out and they killed a bunch of the neighbors farm animals and they,
they didn't just kill one and ate it.
They,
they killed them for pleasure.
So most of the time I think wolves,
when they're killing,
they're killing out of starvation.
They're killing it because they want to eat.
But I think they can kill a lot for pleasure to know you got to wolves,
wolves actually kill for pleasure.
That's the,
they,
they might,
if they were fattened up to,
they might just fuck with you and Jack you.
But the idea of a human evil humans seem to be a lot more capable of evil than
wolves who I,
again,
it's the competition thing.
You know,
it's,
uh,
it's the complexities of the possibilities of emotions.
It can be conjured up,
raising a child and doing a shitty job of doing it and putting the kid in
horrible situations.
And,
and then all of a sudden that,
that what that person is at the most evil barges with a wolf,
you know,
the worst characteristics ever of a human being merged with a wolf.
And that's what a werewolf would be like.
It just horrible psychotic killer animal.
It's about,
it's about
doing what you're doing,
right.
Like Hannibal Lecter freaks me the hell out because he's so aware of exactly
what is inflicting.
And it's like,
and that's what multiply amplifies whatever evil act he's doing is the level of
like satisfaction and it's getting out of it and
not really,
you know,
makes it worse.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it does.
It was always disturbing it.
Well read.
He was and how aware of how fucked up he was,
but he didn't kick.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was one of the most terrifying guys ever.
Yeah.
And that's,
uh,
in the,
you know,
there was two versions of him too.
Did you ever see the first movie?
Uh,
God,
it was dragon's blood or something like that.
The very far,
what was the very,
there was a prequel to that.
Right.
It came out later,
but it was,
I think I had enough when I saw someone eating their own brain,
I was like,
I'm never going to forget this.
It's going to haunt me for the rest of my life.
Dragging the,
that's what it,
it was,
and they made that a movie later.
They eventually,
yeah,
he had that Tattoo and that might might've been the one that freaked me out.
That's,
that's,
that's where he's torturing the old,
uh,
in,
in rich guy
anyway,
I think so.
I think scary old man,
I can't remember.
I don't remember who the Hannibal Lecter was either,
but he was very subtle.
It was a very different,
towards a different actor.
It wasn't Hopkins.
No,
it was,
uh,
some other guy.
But um,
yeah,
that's,
uh,
that idea of the genius that wants to kill you,
that doesn't have any remorse whatsoever.
And it's doing it because it's the only thing that gives them any sort of a
feeling.
Yeah,
that's a terrible,
terrifying thought.
That's way scarier than robots,
right?
White people.
I think it's why people are the scariest thing,
you know.
So we have to worry about cyborgs,
not robots,
robots.
Maybe we'll save us from the sidewalks.
It's all on the table.
No,
I don't can imagine it becomes like what if it becomes the first country that
commits their,
their,
their army to becoming robot cyborgs.
I mean,
this is like a question with,
with whether we should implant ourselves,
you know,
and use neural implants to do things because you think to yourself,
well,
like,
okay,
you know,
we have all this bio ethics and,
and we've decided that it's not ethical for people to do this because everyone
would have to get one in order to compete,
right?
So we're going to out loan and then it's like,
oh,
in China,
their,
their state,
they're mandated by the state and they're getting real productive over there.
And it's like,
oh,
you know,
you think about sort of,
you have a macrocosm view and then you have like a microcosm.
Microcosm is everybody in my kid's classroom,
uh,
went to the doctor and got diagnosed with Adhd and now all these kids have a
neural implant and there are always smarter than my kid will in the macrocosm is
like that,
but applied to like a whole nation,
you know,
that we're competing with
dude,
that would freak you out if he were the only kid that had a natural brain class
and all the other kids had chips in their heads and you couldn't fuck with
anything.
They were saying there's a super sweet,
sweet outer limits that's all about that.
Where there's this one kid whose brain doesn't allow him to get this.
So he's basically not on like all the Internet and social networks and then all
the other kids get their
brains fried by like a virus and he's the only one that's,
that's cool.
And he reads books and stuff and he saves everybody is,
I liked the outer limits.
The outer limits has an awesome fucking show.
I love the idea of the possibilities at science fiction presents.
I just love that there's so many different,
when you stop and think,
especially like we were talking about lost in space when they really had no idea
what the future was going to be like.
And you get to see what their vision of it was.
It's so fascinating to me.
Almost more fascinating than when we like promethium to me,
like what we're going to be capable of.
It's like,
can I ask you where you doing a little bit of Microsoft touch in there and you
know,
you know,
oh,
she created a whole different environment.
She's got,
she now,
she thinks she's in the desert.
Look her.
I haven't seen you.
Haven't seen I should say I got a two year old.
I can't see anything.
You know what man?
Um,
it's,
it's hard to live up to the alien series and it doesn't really,
it stumbles a little bit,
but it's still,
I,
I seen it more than once.
I've seen it again in the hotel room.
I was bored,
so I watched it again.
It's a bad ass movie.
I mean,
visually it's stunning.
Visually alone.
It's worth watching because there's some incredible scenes in it just visually,
but the uh,
the future,
like the technology they present,
it doesn't seem much different than what we were capable of right now.
That stuff really does,
you know,
influence actual science.
Like you know,
people will take clips from these movies and everything is show them during
their presentations and saying,
this is like what we're doing specifically minority report where he's doing
that.
I mean that was huge for human computer interaction.
Hci People like suddenly that clip we're showing up like everywhere at
conferences and people are like,
this is what we're doing.
Do you think we're going to get away from the keyboard interface and the near
future?
There's so much research that's going into natural human interfaces because we
have all this machinery upstairs that's got us geared to interacting with other
human beings.
The way we interact.
Face recognition,
speech recognition,
gesture recognition,
emotion recognition.
You know,
what I'm really impressed with is a speech recognition on,
there's a,
the iPhone has a native app that comes with it called notes and those notes,
when you go to enter into a new note,
it has this little,
this little button that you can press that looks like an old school microphone
and you can just press it and you talk into it and you know Daniel H.
Wilson is a bad motherfucker,
so that's it.
And boom,
it reads it.
Dude bind doesn't do that.
I have to figure out is that it's right at the bottom of the keyboard to the
left of the space bar.
You see how awesome it is?
Yeah.
I mean,
I just said it for the folks at home who are listening to this,
I just said that into my phone and it's an instantly printed up exactly what I
said.
Daniel H.
Wilson is a bad motherfucker.
Even spelled spelled bad motherfucker correctly.
Have you done this yet?
Texts,
Paris Hilton.
I want to eat her asshole.
Hey man,
that's just
rude.
What if the Paris Hilton was listening to this?
To Paris Hilton.
All right.
Sound good.
And it says,
I went to eat your ass hole and I'll send it,
I'll send it.
But Luckily series down is when your phone or to Siri just know.
Huh?
Serious.
Looked it up.
It's like,
oh,
you can't see it there.
Well that sounds what you just did was very rude young man.
If he really did send her that you are abusing technology,
you're a part of the problem.
I'd ever Siri,
Daddy,
I didn't do it.
Even if she wanted her asshole lifts,
she probably doesn't want you bringing it up like that.
It's like Jesus,
can we like talk about it in private after a couple of cocktails and we don't
need yeah,
I like it.
Okay.
I like it when I'm clean,
but uh,
I don't need it to be on a podcast.
Bitch,
you're rude dude.
I just want you to,
every morning,
seven 30 before she leaves the house.
You are a,
you're a book robot.
Apocalypse is a New York Times bestselling book.
That's pretty,
that's a pretty dope thing attached to your name,
New York Times bestselling author.
I know,
man.
I love it.
I got into my Twitter handle,
I'm going to eventually get over it,
but for now I'm still really into,
no,
why would you get over that?
You're legit.
That's like what everybody wants.
Your,
you're like,
that makes you like a black belt in writing.
I think it really is important because it's in,
in when you're writing for a living is really hard to convey to people whether
you're doing all right or not because people,
you'll be out of party and no one knows who the hell y'all,
you're a writer,
right?
I mean,
why would they,
it doesn't really matter how successful you get.
They're not going to know who you are and you're at a party and someone says,
what do you do?
You know?
And you're like,
I write science fiction for a living.
And they're like,
well good luck with that man.
Like that works out.
And it's like,
well no,
I'm,
I'm doing okay.
Like you know,
we can talk about it.
It's not embarrassing.
Like,
oh that's funny.
So they automatically assume that you are failed.
Yeah,
I think so.
Because you're not Stephen King's it cause it's really hard to make a living
writing science fiction.
I mean it's actually scary.
I mean the,
the understanding is if you say I write science fiction for a living,
the understanding is you do not get paid and you have another job.
That's interesting because I would think that there would be a big market for
that.
It seems to be,
yeah,
it seems to me there's a lot of people that are science fiction buff science
fictions killing it.
But like yet it's,
it's still sort of got all this like bad image problems from like the pulp era.
You know like so that's like double day.
My publisher,
they,
they promoted the book as a techno thriller,
not science fiction.
It's a techno thriller because there's like a science fiction ghetto.
There's like a science fiction sub disjunction.
Yeah.
And if you fall into that then you go into the science fiction.
You don't go into the mainstream popular,
you don't go on the front table.
You go into the science fiction area.
That's so weird.
You know what pisses me off?
It's like you,
science fiction is a bad word.
Like people,
the most popular book is like 50 shades of gray,
like it's fucking fairest science.
What do you think
that's about man,
as a writer and you see this poorly written bondo bondage book and it's doing
really well as Bondo,
not bondo.
That's a shift for your cars bond.
Uh,
you know bondage sadomasochistic weird sexual thing.
There's a puddle and that's about all you're really handsome guy.
Likes to hurt girls.
Doesn't even like do it on purpose or something like that.
I haven't read it.
You read it dude.
I started looking at your eyes.
He was trying to lie to me.
I've seen a lot of people,
I've seen a lot of people reading it in public and I'm also kind of strange.
That's like a porno when I just have a penthouse in public.
I know,
but I kinda,
I kinda like it.
Dirty,
dirty bitch.
Yeah,
you're right.
I mean,
think about it that way.
Yeah.
Maybe it's girls like putting out a signal.
Like they're down.
I had a friend who dated this girl and she,
they were normal and he said she,
she got this book,
read the book,
and then the next time they were together she asked him to spit in her mouth and
he was like,
what the fuck?
She goes do it spelling mouth.
And he was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I'm reading this book,
50 shades of gray and I'm just getting really excited about it.
And he was like,
what the fuck are you reading?
So he started like reading like what she was reading and trying to figure out
why she wanted him to spit in her mouth.
I was at a,
or Econ is this science fiction convention in Portland,
right?
So we have a hotel room for the SCIFI convention and my friend rents porno right
on the TV.
And at the beginning,
and I've never seen this before,
at the beginning before they played the porn,
right?
There's a message that says these are unrealistic scenarios.
Do not try this.
These people are like trained.
It was like the whole like,
do not try this at home.
And then of course it's just typical pornography,
right?
Just very large objects going in very small places.
And it's true.
Like I don't know if that's just a hotel thing that's just like nothing.
But you can imagine that hotels are like,
we really need to have a,
you know,
have a,
a little disclaimer at the beginning of his people are hurting each other.
They're getting,
they're getting rowdy.
Oh we're spending a fortune on sheets.
If you talk to anybody that's in the medical profession that's done any work in
the emergency room,
they would tell you about all the various things that people stuffed in their
body and then got stuck up there.
And it's,
it's crazy man.
I had a friend who they had to pull a light bulb by this dude's ass,
one of those twisty light bulbs.
You,
those like they're slightly thicker glass cause it Kinda twisty.
Elisa wasn't a fluorescent broken.
It had broken in his ass.
They had to pull this out of his ass.
Dude,
like gingerly had to like walk him cause he was afraid that if he closed down on
his ass it would shatter inside of his ass and just shards.
And there's a video of a guy doing that very thing.
It's a video of a guy with a cop.
Oh my God,
it's horrific this time he,
he doesn't do what a light bulb but he does it with a Collagen,
which is even because it's a
heavy shot glass jar and it breaks off inside of him and he's pulling these
chunks of glass with blood and it's all falling out of his ass and is one of the
most disturbing things you could ever see on the Internet and welcome.
Keep in mind if you see it,
you can't unsee.
Yeah,
you don't want to see it but you do want to see it.
I can't even watch to know.
I don't like it cause it's harsh.
I just feel like Tasha is,
should just rename it to somebody is about to get a compound fracture.
Wait for it.
He's like the new faces of death and you never know.
Right.
It could just be like some old lady crossing the street or like a guy taking a
drink of milk and then compound fracture.
You want to see a broken toe,
a horrifically broken toe.
Oh,
I gotta look at it.
Isn't yours?
No.
Anthony [inaudible].
He's a fighter.
Fights in the UFC and he just had to withdraw from a fight because of a broken
toe.
It's pretty incredible.
You want to see it?
Do you want to say it?
I like to,
I like to use the VCR method and lower the resolution by squinting.
Yeah.
Okay.
Then I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna show it to,
I'm not going to show it to you,
but it's one of the craziest things I've ever seen.
I did that look good or I do like the thing where I'm just looking at the bottom
left of the screen,
so I'm like,
I could see it like an arm.
Yeah.
You remember the first time you saw like someone die on online,
like the first video of like the Budd Dwyer video or something like that.
You're like,
Oh wow,
that's a guy dying.
That's what it looks like when someone dies.
Well,
you used to have to like go through all the trouble to get faces of death.
It was a huge deal.
And you know,
now it's like you're waiting for the bus.
It's like I think I'm gonna Watch 15 people die.
Faces a death was the same era for me as a friend who had one of those barn yard
porns.
There was a few of those portions that were going around that were like so
grainy and CD and just,
Oh,
just horrendous.
You just got to think about what it was like to be this poor girl.
There was this blowing this donkey and the actual VHS tapes are always sticky.
Sticker's ripped off.
Sometimes you,
the tape would get fucking broken and spool up and there were horrible,
horrible videos and it was like the resolution was terrible,
you know?
But,
but at least there was like a little bit of pageantry.
Yes,
that's the wrong word.
No,
but gravity associated with the whole act of witnessing this terrible thing.
It wasn't so easy.
You're right.
It was a big deal.
Like we planned it out.
Like one guy even had to watch the door,
right?
Like one guy watched the door and we watched it downstairs on this light is at
the bottom.
Like he was like,
he stood like halfway up the stairs so he could like still lean down and look
over at this.
It was a little shitty ass fucking television.
We were watching this on and when we were watching that girl below the horse
were like,
what the fuck we talk,
we could go to jail at any moment.
Someone could cause going to kick the door in.
I don't remember how old we were,
but it wasn't more than like high school age.
It was somewhere around high school age.
It was just the craziest thing to see ever to watch this check off sex with
animals.
Like there was a dog,
she,
she blew a dog.
She will a donkey.
Like there was a couple of different animals that she had her have sex with.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
That was so hard to do.
It's like,
and we felt bizarre for like days afterwards.
You know,
it's kind of like,
Hey,
kids today,
they just laugh about that shit.
They think it's hilarious.
Yeah.
Rolls off of them.
I mean,
they,
they witnessed so much more,
so much faster than we ever did.
And I dunno.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a weirdness to this life for them that just never existed for as far as
we know,
for any human ever.
This,
this weird connection to almost anything.
If you leave your kid out in the world with an iPhone,
when you send them out in the world,
you're giving them access to fucking everything.
That's the whole world.
I mean,
they're not going to probably get taken by Internet scammers from their iPhone,
but almost everything else,
there's a times article right now where they're interviewing people like a bunch
of different people about porn in whom the impact on society and then that
there's somebody that says exactly that.
They're like,
look,
you know,
kids have access to everything.
It's really impossible to limit that access.
And so,
and they're talking about how all this easy access to porn has affected people's
sex lives.
And apparently,
uh,
you know,
certain they go through and they catalog which sex acts occur in the majority of
videos.
So they can say like 88% of videos have a facial,
you know,
and then they look and they,
there's a direct correlation.
What happens in those videos is,
is what people want to do a at home,
you know,
that's funny.
So like,
but sex goes way up.
They said like 80% had bud sacs and then 4% of people actually had bought sex,
which is,
what do you mean 80% in the video?
The video,
90% of the people who did it,
but in real life,
4% of people.
Yeah,
because there's a correlation between demands and what's in the videos.
Not so much a correlation between what actually happens because the gatekeepers
in this whole process or the females.
Well that's why we like go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
What's,
we have really talked about like it must be so crazy in the gay community
because there's
female.
I said the same thing to her.
I said,
thank God you guys are slowing us down and God knows what's happening in that
community because there's no break.
Yeah.
Believe me,
there's no way it would be the same if men and women and we're the same,
like as far as like our voracity.
It would be just like gay people and it's not,
you know,
the,
the men have to tone down for the women.
It's a,
it doesn't exist in the gay community and they have a totally different bizarre
operating dynamic.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well I'm sure that,
that everybody acclimated to it.
I guess they have
suppression though,
that way,
you know,
certainly they know each other,
they understand each other better.
Yeah.
I think that that also,
that relationship,
whenever you have gay friends and you see how the relationships,
you know,
to the extent that,
that you see that if you're,
if you're a heterosexual and you're,
I mean obviously you're not seeing the whole story.
They're not seeing your whole story and your bedroom either.
But I think that the,
those types of relationships,
each person has their own specific one and it affects each other.
You see that?
Like,
you know,
uh,
my friends that are gay tend to have like relationships where they trust each
other a lot and,
and they're a little looser.
It's not a lot of jealousy and stuff.
Maybe I just have weird friends.
I don't know.
But,
uh,
but it's interesting,
you know,
you rub off on each other.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's interesting that they,
it's like I just,
it's just a different dynamic,
you know?
And for whatever reason,
the real issue lies in the fact that it's not legal everywhere,
that they don't share the same rights as people everywhere.
That to me is really bizarre because if two people want to pretend to be the
husband,
why,
what do you give a fuck?
As long as they're together,
you know,
if one guy wants to pretend he's a woman,
what do you care?
Why do you care?
They're just two people that want to get married.
And the idea that you,
you would have to be,
have a certain sexual proclivity in order to engage in this marital contract.
This is so bizarre.
And if you allow any sort of bizarre,
any sort of discrimination that doesn't make any sense of objectively,
if you allow any of that in our world,
then it's going to come at you too,
man.
And if you don't take a stand for gay people that want to get married and the
first whatever reason,
they're being persecuted by numbskulls and overly religious crazy people,
if you don't take a stand for them,
then who's going to take a stand for you when it comes in your direction?
Who's going to take a stand for humanity because it's just a person who happens
to like men.
Why do you let them marry each other?
You fuck,
what do you care?
Yeah,
it doesn't make any sense.
I think there are a lot of like cultural mores or whatever,
right?
However you pronounce that word,
like sort of stuff that people just think is obvious,
you know?
And it's just accepted.
But Times change,
you know,
people are relationships.
How human beings interact with each other.
You know,
even just like you think about people interacting over the computer,
stuff like that.
All that stuff changes.
And so all of the cultural stuff has to change too.
And you know,
sometimes I'm,
I'm glad that we do have a full spectrum of,
some people are just willing to embrace anything new,
right?
And especially with technology,
you have all kinds of new shit getting thrown at us.
Like all the time,
other people dig in their heels and they say,
let's take it slow,
you know,
let's not go nuts here.
And I think that's a good thing because we have so much change coming at us so
fast that we need some people that are willing to embrace it and experiment with
it.
Other people that are,
and I'm not,
I'm off of the gay thing now,
by the way,
I'm on the technology.
I'm just going to talk to you about this.
I'm until like,
I'm on to like people who are saying,
you know,
um,
like that,
that,
that we shouldn't,
is experiment with like stem cells and that we shouldn't,
you know,
all of this like scientific,
uh,
discovery that's out there and people are saying,
no,
no.
We shouldn't study it.
We should slow down.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it is nice to,
to,
to have some people that want to slow things down.
Well,
it's,
it's bizarre when religion actually tries to interfere with science in,
in,
in ways that don't make any sense.
Like one of my favorite ones was the pope talking to Stephen Hawkings and he
told him that it
was okay to explore the nature of the universe,
but it wasn't okay to explore the origins of the big bang because that would be
like questioning God himself.
Isn't that hilarious?
Religions to me,
like he was like telling him what I mean,
this was like our lifetime and I'll,
I mean,
Hawkings still alive.
So this was in our lifetime.
The pope was telling this guy,
he's still studying the big bang.
It's just,
it's so silly that that could ever get to a point where it can happen where this
nutty cult member actually could get into a position.
And in this day and age,
that could mean it didn't have an influence other than to make a humorous
anecdote.
But it's still,
what if he listens his notions really.
I mean,
who knows what his own psychological proclivity might be.
There are some people that are subject to the influence of people that you
wouldn't be or I wouldn't be.
And it uh,
you know,
in certain cases,
like someone who is in a big position of power,
like a pope.
Well,
you know,
for thousands and thousands of years,
religion is the bedrock.
It's what keeps people United.
It's what keeps him alive.
I mean to have a shared culture,
you know,
I'm,
I'm like I have native American in my background,
right.
And I'm always really growing up,
I was always interested in reading the history and thinking about,
you know,
why did native Americans get basically wiped out and also aborigines and things.
And you think about the fact that like in Australia,
all the different tribes in Australia,
they all spoke different languages and they were all like,
they all had a certain amount of land and they were kind of in stasis.
I mean they,
they fought with each other but,
but everything always kind of ended up the same.
There was no one group that conquered all of Australia.
And then you think about Europe and other more bellicose places.
China,
you know,
you've got here,
you've got places where they in force one culture on massive groups of people,
right through religion and they're incredibly effective.
Then they travel all over the world and white people out.
They worked together,
they build cities.
There's great utility in having people like my,
you know,
think alike like this.
But then you know,
there's also a drawback.
The drawback can be that it's resistant to change and it doesn't,
uh,
you know,
adapt for nuisance new circumstances.
So it's almost like you could look at religion as an operating system on a cell
phone.
It allows you to get things done,
but if you don't update it and continually updated with the latest versions,
well science naturally updates itself.
You can always go back and prove something wrong,
prove it for yourself,
fix it,
update it with new information.
I mean,
that's the strength of science.
But that's scary because you,
there is no bedrock and you know how much you don't know.
And you really have to trust yourself a lot,
I think,
to,
to really trust science because you are acknowledging that you don't know
everything.
You're allowing a thought into your mind that a lot of people do not find
comforting.
And that is no one is watching this thing.
No one's paying attention to then that we essentially live in a soup of madness
now.
And that is,
that is the world that we actually exist in.
And we want to pretend that we're in this strange Sandra Bullock movie where
everything's gonna be okay and everything's going to be normal.
And one of the best ways to do that is to think that there was a guy that lived
a long time ago that came back from the dead and he's,
he absolved you of all your bullshit.
You just got to take them into your heart and your good no matter how bad you've
been in the past.
Well,
and they go with that.
It's not about you believing,
it's about lots of people believing it's that you draw strength on other people.
Yes.
Good point.
I think it's a natural human thing to do.
I think it's not wrong system.
I think it's like a scaffolding for morals.
I think of it as a policy.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's a set of behaviors,
you know,
for certain situations will behave this way and,
and yeah,
and it glues people together and sort of like when a guy wears a suit and a tie,
he's going to be a gentleman.
The gentleman with the gentlemen care for a drink,
you know,
I mean it got us to say that if you're wearing like Moy Thai shorts and flip
flops and you sweat and you know,
I don't want to have anything to do with you.
They wouldn't say with the gentleman liker cocktail,
the bill like,
sorry,
you can't come in here naked with flip flops on.
You know,
we want you to look in this very specific uniform way and that is a,
that's how I know I can predict your behavior.
You're going to behave like a gentleman.
Well that,
believe it or not,
I can make anything tie back to robotics,
but I believe you could that that actually ties back in when you build a robot,
right?
What you choose to make it look like is a promise.
It's a guarantee to the person that's going to interact with it.
So if you build a robot that looks just exactly like a human being than anybody
that walks up to that robot is it's going to damn well expect that that robot is
going to be as smart as a human being.
If you say what's up buddy?
It's going to say,
hey there pal.
And if it doesn't,
people get mad,
you know,
which is why I don't think we're going to see super realistic like androids
anytime soon because we don't have the full package.
You know,
we may be able to make it look really realistic,
but we can't make it behave in a really realistic way.
Why is that?
I mean,
just because that's the hard part is that,
I mean it's,
it's a temporary hurdle isn't it?
I mean with the way science continually grows in this exponential manner to see
if they could figure out,
they can sort of figure out how to mimic various aspects of the actual human.
Yeah.
I mean we're making progress,
but you think they'll actually engineering egos and things like that?
Yeah.
I mean self-respect.
They'll copy it.
They'll make it,
they'll mimic it to the extent that you can't tell the difference.
What if they,
what if robots start like revenge beatings waiting for people behind cars and
people talk shit at don't on a door knobs beat the fuck out.
I think that'd be a math function.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it would be.
You would have to,
is there a way you could ever like in the alien
series,
like we've been engineered to never harm a human being.
I love those aliens row.
I love Bishop.
She can't
no fucked up.
Like the first guy was good too,
man.
The first guy was good to spoiler alert.
Spoiler alert.
It permeates.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What's the most
substantial?
That awesome actor.
Yeah.
That dude,
I don't remember his name.
David named him too.
Which is yeah.
Which is weird.
All right.
I'll tell you who he is.
We'll give the guy his proper credit.
Yeah.
But he's amazing in it.
It's um,
folks,
that dude's name.
I am DB.
We're done.
I am beep beep.
That movie.
He got a 7.3 rating.
That's pretty fucking good.
That is our in home boy.
What's his name?
So they announced we got Anne Hathaway is going to be and rub apocalypse and
hassle.
Ish came official yesterday.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't even know what parts you're going to play,
but I'm kind of excited.
She's sort of a bad ass.
Is she really?
Well,
I mean as Catwoman and stuff like she pulled it off any,
any of that superhero stuff.
If you can dress up in a gimmicky costume and make it and pull it off and make
it seem real,
then you've got my respect.
Right.
Can't find this dude.
I see.
I should know his name.
God Damn it really?
Is it Rafe?
Spall?
No,
no.
That's not it
on the fucker.
All right.
I give up.
I give up props to him,
whoever it is,
whoever he is.
He's a bad motherfucker.
I don't seem,
they don't seem to have his photo here in the cast.
He was the robot guy or it's not Guy Pearce.
I don't know.
Um,
I give up.
Sorry.
Is it people are screaming his name right now.
Yeah.
I'm sure someone on Twitter will tell me who the guy's name is,
but yeah,
he,
he played an amazing robot.
He did the best job in my opinion,
in any robot movie of walking that creepy line where you think he almost feel
slighted but doesn't because he really doesn't have any program motions,
but he's recognizing that you're trying to slight him.
Yeah.
You know,
it's very fascinating.
It's like,
it's worth seeing really a,
for some of his scenes alone,
especially,
I don't want,
I can't tell you too much
like a really realistic humanoid or android.
I mean like there's a momentum behind the emotions,
right?
So even if it doesn't feel pissed off,
if it looks and all the other ways behaves completely consistently with how a
human would behave,
then you're going to be sitting there waiting on him to be pissed off.
And even if his face is totally blank,
you're probably going to project on it and be like,
yes.
Is he a little pissed off?
Because everything else is consistent,
but okay,
so he's designed not to be pissed off.
That's somehow,
it's hard to believe whenever you have a full working model of how people behave
and it's been trained on people.
We'll also,
the guy's
name was Michael Fassbender.
Michael Fassbinder.
Yeah.
Spoiler alert.
Also in,
he actually acts in almost stay vindictive manner to one of the guys who had
been fucking with them in this,
uh,
in this movie.
It was kind of interesting.
I got to see how they,
uh,
they had had it set up it,
you know,
it wasn't,
like I said,
it wasn't a terrible movie.
It just wasn't what I was hoping it was going.
Michael Fassbender,
that's it.
Is he played David.
He was the second one.
There it is.
He's just,
his hair's a different color in this photo.
I got confused.
But yeah,
he's an amazing actor,
man.
That guys,
it's a,
that's a,
that's a skill that it's going to be difficult when they start doing CGI movies,
like completely CGI,
like really replicating an actual humans emotions and the way a human like that
guy can act,
that's going to be really difficult to do.
It's,
it's all the little things that the actors learned.
I was watching,
I watched snow,
I've been watching all the Chris Hemsworth movies because he's also supposed to
be in Rome apocalypse.
Who's Chris Hemsworth?
Thor.
Mighty.
Oh cool.
And he's in red dawn and the remake and he's in Snow White and the Huntsman,
he's,
yes.
So I was watching that and I can't remember the name of the actors who,
she's the one from twilight in Stewart and she does this,
she's,
you know,
really pretty.
And she does this thing where you start to notice like that it's like almost her
trademark.
Like she breeds really hard and then her collarbones sort of stick out,
you know?
And it's like,
that's like an acting thing.
Like,
or when you notice their little nostrils are flipping around and you're like,
that's why they get paid the big bucks.
That's his nostrils.
Or like doing seaworld shit and flipping out of the water and yeah.
That's funny.
Yeah.
They uh,
they have very,
some people like they,
the same guy in it,
like Christopher Walken,
he's the same guy and like almost alien movie ever.
Right.
I read an interview with him.
He said that they started,
like,
now he has a clause in his contract that says they can't rewrite it to make it
weirder when they hire him because he's tired of all the roles shaping to fit
him instead of him having to act.
It's funny,
like,
so as he gets it,
hey look,
we're going to have Christopher Walken and he's going to be on acid 24,
seven and he only wears like flippers and golf shoes and shit like that around
the house.
And it was this supposed to be someone's like dad or something?
Yeah.
Wonderful.
Like the variety of roles that he gets offered.
Everyone's crazy.
Everyone.
Every role that he does.
It's got to be a crazy guy.
And once you get type cast,
I guess I'll Buccino like he's got a screen,
it's gotta be at least one ranting screaming scene in every movie.
I think after a while these two dudes probably like,
they probably get like,
especially after the,
they get paid a few times,
like they really like sell out hard and it makes them fat cash on a terrible
movie.
And I'm like,
wow,
that was pretty easy.
It's versus good problems,
you know?
Oh,
I keep getting hired and getting paid a lot of money to be myself.
But like Robert Deniro did a bunch of stinky ass movies,
man,
he did that one movie where he was like a Gremlin or a warlock or something like
that.
Wasn't there a movie where like it was like one of those things
type rip offs?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I feel like God,
I can't remember.
Oh,
you know,
I saw a,
nobody saw it in Snow White.
There were all these dwarves.
Right.
And I thought that they were a little buddy and,
uh,
and instead they were,
they were real actors.
You have it,
they see it.
I couldn't figure out how it was happening.
Like,
yeah.
Most famous actors.
Yeah.
That was a,
that was a big point of contention with the little people community because they
were like,
what the fuck man?
Like these are the only gigs that we could take.
And instead you think it's cute to show off with a,
you know,
like there's plenty of little people,
actors that would have loved those roles.
So it's kind of a,
that was a little touch and go situation.
Like,
was it a hot bod bud hot,
what's his name?
Hot Skins.
What is the guy's name?
Uh,
what roles does he play?
He was one of the little people.
Very famous.
Fuck God dammit.
Now I'm going to make me imtp this mother fucker too.
I might be MDM more today than I ever have in my life.
But,
uh,
then there was the other movie
you can tell imdv was one of the first websites because it's got,
because they would never name it that,
right.
If they would be like,
they would give it a
like that.
Yeah.
Why am I am DP Internet movie database?
I guess it's easy to remember.
It's four characters,
man.
You can't get a website that's four characters.
Baas hot skins,
that's homeboy's name.
He's been in a gang of movies.
Well,
as he Hoskins Bob Hoskins was in,
um,
wasn't he in Roger Rabbit and that too?
Yeah,
he was willow and star wars and like spinning fucking everything has been in a
lot of shit.
He's been a lot of shit.
But uh,
he's in that movie too.
See,
I feel the same way about in robot apocalypse.
That's all native Americans like,
so I have this feeling that if the federal government were to fall apart,
there are all these sovereign tribal governments that are around,
that have jails and cops and hospitals and everything that you need.
Right.
Only it's smaller and a,
and in the book,
like everybody ends up there.
And so in the movie,
I don't know,
I haven't read the script,
I don't know anything about it,
but I'm like wondering are they going to hire native actors?
You know,
Indians because it's like an Osage army basically.
It would just have to maybe look a little bit more carefully,
but I'm sure there's plenty of qualified people acting as one of those things
too,
man.
There's a lot of people that you don't know that can do it.
It's,
it's,
it's one of those things where there's so many people at the Dunn Theater and
they can't fucking act.
They know how to act good at like getting people that aren't big names and
scouting and making them their names,
but at least while they're with him.
Well,
you know,
I think when you've been in the movie business that long,
you trust like casting agents too.
And like a casting agent can tell you,
hey,
this kid,
he's been,
you know,
he's amazing.
You got to check him out.
Nobody knows who he is.
Basically.
It's really got something special and he's perfect for this one particular role
that he might have,
you know?
But he's,
he's good at it,
but some people just,
it's cool.
It's kind of funny that we have this thing with movies where we accept that
we're seeing the same guy over and over and over again in a bunch of different
lives.
Mass.
That one movie.
He's the last Samaritan Samurai,
whatever the fuck he is in another movie.
He's a vampire.
He's going to be Jack a trip.
The guy from the,
who is it?
Clive Cussler or something?
Oh Man.
From what movie's terrible dude.
We're fucking up today.
Yeah,
he's uh,
I need some bulletproof coffee.
He's playing a guy who is actually like six foot four linebacker.
Oh,
he's playing,
is he?
Oh No,
I was just thinking of um,
Matthew.
Matt Damon.
Didn't Matt Damon play a rugby player?
A famous rugby player?
He could pull.
Thank you.
Did was like you can pull it off
fairly.
No,
I mean he played the Bourne identity.
Great.
Yeah,
I bought that.
I was,
although I bought the new guy more,
I bought the new guy.
I believe the new guy was more like natural as a killer.
Who was the new Jeremy Renner?
Is that his name?
Renner.
Yeah.
Hey,
we knew someone whose name today.
That guy is a bad ass.
I thought what I found was amazing about that movie though was that one of the
things about that movie is that this guy can endure like incredible cold and
pain.
He could do all these amazing things physically and yet he also had incredible
discipline and he never chased pussy.
It's like they made him the most unrealistic superhero ever because like I was
thinking about,
they were going over James Bond today and then we're talking about a,
on the Ron and fair show,
they were talking about all the different names for the James Bond women and
which one was the hottest and which girl,
which James Bond girl.
They had a weakness because they portray that as his great strength.
Yes.
He's a great strange seeing women.
He's doing this too.
They're powerless.
Instead of he's getting Patraeus,
you know,
he's just not real.
He's not even trying to get laid.
He's like,
he has no needs whatsoever sexually,
but yet he flips through the air and lands on top of the roofs and beats.
You should everybody and carries this woman the whole way.
But she just wants like that is like the ideal man.
Women was pants vampire that won't suck your blood and can go out in the
daytime.
He just sparkles.
They want,
I mean they want this super bad ass who doesn't want any pussy at all?
He's just your guard dog that he takes care of you everywhere.
He doesn't even try to fuck you.
Like this woman is unbelievably beautiful and he's saving her through the entire
movie and they never even so much to make [inaudible] no,
no it's not.
Okay.
It's Jeremy Renner and one of the new Bourne identity cause I was okay,
but I'm saying at the same time,
if you go back and look like they had a bond movie called octopussy.
Yeah,
I mean that was the most unsettled play on words ever.
I remember my grandfather had that VHS tape and I was like,
aw yeah.
I like grab that one,
popped it in.
As soon as he,
as a doorway,
he's getting hot freaks.
That was part of being bond.
He got
laid like crazy and it was a good thing back then.
But in 90 more superhero can't do that anymore.
It's the new bond to philanthropy.
I don't know,
is he,
does he go,
does he go and get some mass in this new movie blasting mean it's his trademark.
He's going to have a Martini is going to go chase them ass gun.
Yeah,
he's going to win always in the end he'll be fine.
You know,
he might have a little cast on his hand or some shit like that,
but in the end to like meet the queen or something.
I heard Heineken hate a bunch of money so that he only drinks Heineken Beers
during the,
uh,
it's unsubstantiated but it will be seen the video,
the commercial rather than the,
that's pretty well done commercial for a beer commercial.
It was going that way already cause they had all those commercials with dudes
flipping through the air and he's just kind of a bond desk kind of bad ass.
Yeah.
So I guess that's okay honey.
It's all iconic.
Can Sucks.
I think it pay him to only drink Heineken.
What's wrong with that?
And I like kind of Ken.
Yeah,
it's the principle of it.
What is the principle?
The principle is that it's product placement in a bond movie,
which is semi sacrilegious.
Is that it?
Is it,
I mean I don't know a lot of what movie it is.
It kind of does.
So there's certain things like bond that are like sacred bonds.
You've got to go Sean Connery,
Moore,
mission impossible if you want to,
if you want to.
I want to only drink like if you want a whore out your main character now bond
during the Pierce Brosnan era with cars.
Right.
I was like,
wait a minute.
But he wasn't bond.
Did Daniel Craig is bond.
Okay.
Daniel Craig looks like a real English bad motherfucker that could snap your
neck cuts.
The consignors Morgan was,
what's his name?
Not Pierce Morgan Pierce Brosnan.
Pierce Brosnan.
He seemed like a very nice guy and I bet he's a hell of a good actor.
Seems like an English gentleman.
He did.
I did not buy him kicking people's asses.
I buy this Daniel Craig Guy fucking people up and killing people.
I totally buy it.
He's more compact and like Daniel Craig.
Yeah,
Craig.
He's built like a pit bull.
Yeah,
he's like thick like that guy looks like an athlete.
Like when you see him with his shirt off and he's got a gun in his hand.
You believe that's a god kills people for a living.
You know?
That's it.
That's a real special agent.
Where's the Pierce Brosnan?
I was like,
bitch,
I'm want to take your gun.
You can't hold onto that gun.
Killing that thing.
Your hair.
Yes.
I was going to hold you down.
Pee on you.
You're just,
I just don't buy it.
Roger Moore.
At least we got the tongue and cheek and it was a different era.
Pierce Brosnan was in this weird sort of like nineties drama to an action.
I've got a theory about this too.
I got a lot of theories,
by the way,
my theory on this,
and they're like,
there's 80s and nineties late eighties early nineties there's all these movies
where if the action scenes consist of people holding submachine guns and go on
each other,
right.
Or there'll be like way up on the catwalk and they'll have a shotgun and then
like boom,
boom shooting somebody like way the fuck across the warehouse.
And my theory is that you can't get away with that shit anymore because every
kid plays call of duty.
No,
a shotgun.
Is it effective at long range?
I mean this is like in the DNA of every 14 year old boy.
You just know that you can't
shoot somebody with a shotgun from across a football field.
It's not.
You might have never touched a shotgun.
And so like the whole spraying the sub machine gun thing and that stuff is gone
now you got to be way more brutal and like accurate and realistic about it.
Well that's why martial arts movies don't look like those early,
you know,
like John Claude van Damme and those early martial arts movies.
It's harder to buy this guy,
you know,
flipping you over his head and grabbed me by the risk.
When you see like an MMA fight,
realize what really happened.
I was watching demolition man and like Wesley snipes is like fuck,
are you doing like roundhouse kicks like four,
five,
six.
Yeah,
it's still standing there.
He was really,
yeah.
Acting real roundhouse kick.
Like when does that even ever happen?
Right.
But you know,
it's just like,
it's like watching home alone or something.
Yeah.
That brick would have caved in his skull and you going have immediately thrown
up all over the floor.
You know the police would have come,
there was a bunch of movies,
those martial arts movies that were completely ridiculous.
We're dudes would just get stand in a circle and the guys would just charge out
up to the left and he would take,
kick him and then the guy would charged on a ride.
He would kick him and it,
nobody ever,
nobody ever washed them all at one time.
Man Norris,
this is,
this is his bread and butter.
Chuck Norris and some of the greatest movies ever.
Texas is a beautiful show episode.
Keep going.
Get come a couple more times on the stock.
He,
dude,
there was an episode where he,
a bomb went off and he lost his sight and he went and he meditated and he got a
sight back at the end and save.
Somebody had to get a site back to save somebody that was like,
my God,
it gets a little spiritual does he's all
he chuck Norris is is is very high on Jesus.
I met Chuck Norris.
It was one of the proudest moments of my life that Chuck Norris knew who I was
and it gave me a hug.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
because Chuck Norris swatches the UFC.
I was like,
God dammit.
Why don't I have a camera?
The photo with Chuck Norris in the martial arts community that's akin to like a
photo with Elvis.
If you're a singer,
blow it up.
Yeah.
If you've got a photo of Chuck Norris,
hit those kettlebells and just stare at the photo.
You Know Chuck Louis and Mike Together.
Yeah.
Just motivate me to train hard.
Me.
Chuck Norris had a bunch of unbelievably preposterous movies beat.
I mean,
Chuck Norris is a bad motherfucker,
but some of those movies were
roadhouse,
right?
Is One of the great classic.
That is the classic.
I had some friends in Portland who created a roadhouse musical,
and this is one of the best things I've ever seen.
It's like a roadhouse acting out raw.
Then occasionally there's like songs and there's a narrator that's like,
oh my God.
I was like,
did you guys get permission?
And they're like,
ah,
they just did it.
I just did it.
You know,
it profit or is it just for it will,
you know,
it was for profit,
but they sold out.
I mean,
these are real actors.
I don't think anybody would find it as anything other than you should be
stricken.
Ideally people would look at it and say,
that's a tribute.
You know?
And,
and it's,
it's what keeps people buying the DVDs and keeps exactly investing in the movie.
That was a great bad movie.
It's a great bad movie.
It's got everything.
It's an amazing movie.
Perfect storm.
You know,
like at a certain every sort of genre that you have,
like movies that perfect different elements of the genre and then,
and then you'll have one perfect,
uh,
one or two perfect storm movies that get everything and then,
you know,
and then it dissipates.
The Times Change Code
of silence was one like super legit movie.
The Chuck Norris did that.
I was trying to remember it.
It was a,
a movie like almost like a Charles Bronson type movie where he played a cop.
It's just two hours of him meditating.
Motherfuckers only gave it a 5.6 in the ratings.
How dare you.
I am DB.
I disagree.
I think you got to,
you know,
look at it in the time that it was made,
but at the time that it was made,
it was like Chuck Norris,
his,
it was like,
had very little martial arts in it for a Chuck Norris movie.
It was more of a,
you know,
just a good action drama.
Who,
I mean,
I think he threw like one side kick and the whole movie.
Yeah.
It was more actually obligated to,
yeah,
probably.
Probably.
Yeah.
You can't have a chuck Norris blue.
It doesn't kick at least one dude Chuck Norris.
Look,
no,
it looks great.
Does healthy's the martial artists,
if you're receiving those commercials,
where does those uh,
those,
uh,
what does that thing to police system?
They do those
sizes and shit cause you know,
a lot of the action heroes from that era that are also movie stars,
you know,
they,
there's a lot of sort of surgical stuff that starts creeping in and they start
looking a little funny.
Well,
I'll,
Chuck Norris is,
I think he's in his sixties.
Let's look,
look here.
Um,
but um,
I know he definitely still trains.
He's um,
he was born in 1940.
Whoa.
So,
uh,
that means he's 72.
Dang.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Well he's doing all right.
Healthy lives.
Amazing.
That's amazing.
Well,
he looks incredible for 72.
That's incredible.
Am I retarded?
No,
I'm not.
That's exactly what he is.
Wow.
Um,
he's still very fit though.
If you see him in these,
whatever these things are,
Tim and Christie Brinkley,
I don't remember what they're called.
These cable,
it's essentially a low impact cable police system workout.
And he uh,
he promotes those things and he's a,
he's a black belt in Jujitsu and I'm sure he's still probably does some form of
martial arts still too.
When he looks great for 72,
he's incredible.
But yeah,
a lot of those dudes that fucking have your body doesn't last son.
Shit's gonna go.
And that's where robotics,
hey,
that's why I'm saving mine.
I'm not working out because you only get so many good,
good thinking movements
match.
If it worked that way.
If you were born a fucking superhero and every day your life,
you like your,
your physical points and the more physical activity did the,
the lower your life guide or the candle burns this faster.
Yeah,
it's likely your life would be like almost like a video game know you just have,
everybody would have the equal number to start with.
Well didn't they?
They made that
movie where you have a certain amount of time to live.
Right.
Did you know they're remaking Logan's run?
Others?
Speaking of everybody,
I sat at the science fiction convention.
I sat next to this guy and he's sitting next to me and he's bitching,
you know about like there's not any people here.
And I was like,
he's,
he was older and I was like,
what?
So what,
you know,
what's your deal?
Why are you bitching so hard?
You know?
And he's like,
basically it comes out.
And he was like,
I wrote Logan's run,
you know?
Wow.
I'm like,
you are so lucky that you had a movie made out of your book in the 70s or,
and I think they bought the rights in the 60s that people still remember right.
I mean,
how easy to just go,
you know,
and just be gone.
And he was just better,
it just wasn't happening.
He actually seemed cool.
He was sort of like a little while he was at peace with the fact that in this
world you can show up and a hundred people would be in line to get a book signed
or he can show up and it has to be like,
like nobody,
you know,
or like that one guy that wants to like talk about every aspect of star trek.
And then he sort of wanders off without buying a book.
You're like,
oh,
that's gotta be brutal for 20 minutes.
And you buddy.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
That's got to be annoying for those guys because they're really trying to be
friendly to people,
but they're also trying to sell some shit and get some things end of the day.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're trying to sell a book.
It's got to be weird when I know the,
the book Logan's run,
I remember it,
but I don't remember anything about it.
I don't remember the movie.
And I remember that
the movie was about all these people that basically,
it's like seventies everybody's in unitards and you die whenever you're 30 like,
and if you don't agree to die,
they hunt you down and kill you.
You have like the little gym in your hand.
It starts flashing.
So Logan doesn't want to die basically.
I mean,
I haven't seen the movie in forever and ever,
but he makes a run for it.
I mean,
so it's,
is it,
how much different is it from the Justin Timberlake movie?
Yeah,
right.
That's,
that's what got me thinking about it.
When you have a certain number of points.
Yeah,
not very,
it's not very different.
Um,
that team has been explored.
Well people are always concerned about the idea that one day due to the fact
that we can keep everybody alive and in fact the Pec populations are exploding.
You were,
we're continuing to figure out new diseases and how to cure people when they're
sick and people are staying alive longer.
Like at what point in time do we,
does it become an issue and do they ever need to control and how do you even go
about doing that?
And so all these like scenarios like the Justin Timberlake movie or Logan's run
pop up where the evil government forces you into a contamination process or,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I mean,
again,
I think at its heart it's
about like being afraid that technology is going to change human nature.
Like there are certain things that are in Nate about being human.
Like we're born and we die,
right?
I mean,
come on.
Every single human being as lived and they're all going to,
or they did die already.
And if you change that,
then I mean,
that's scary stuff,
right?
You're going into a completely unknown territory.
And ultimately that's what everybody is shooting for with the height of
technology.
The height of technology is to ascend,
pass the physical,
the physical body to,
to get yourself into a position where you truly become immortal because you
become part of some computer programs.
He,
man,
I don't see,
I don't,
I'm not down with this ray Kurtzweil he doesn't want to die.
Okay.
He doesn't believe that he should have to die.
Yeah,
no,
this is what he says.
I mean,
I understand he doesn't want to die.
And he says,
you know,
one way to avoid it is to have a machine that's going to,
uh,
basically take a snapshot of every neuron in your brain,
which they're all just little switches,
right?
And it's going to figure out exactly what's going to go,
what's going on in your brain.
And then it's going to continue to simulate that.
But like part of me is just saying,
Yo,
when you die,
even if you simulate yourself perfectly,
you're fricking dead.
You're,
you're a pile of debt.
And you know,
there's the other possibility that,
you know,
eat when you're dead and this other life goes on,
like it's going to be completely disconnected from reality and who knows how
it's going to progress.
It's just cause it's a copy of the operating system and all the information and
all the traits that your brain,
how the fuck do you know what that thing is?
Once it's on own,
where they put the criminal guys mind into a machine,
he's like,
they turn him on and he's just like these demonic face.
Like he's totally an agony and screaming and he doesn't know what's happened to
him.
He's lost his embodiment as a human being.
And I mean if you lose your limb,
that mentally screws you up because your brain has a map of,
of who you are.
Right?
And then if you took your whole brain and stuck it into something that wasn't
even a human body,
I mean that shit would mentally traumatized,
traumatized.
It might drive you insane,
you know?
Yeah,
it's a good point.
And then you'd hunt down robocop and tried to give drugs to children.
Well,
W W we don't know what the impact of it would be psychologically to all of a
sudden be trapped in this immortal machine.
You know?
And what if there was,
it became like the ethical considerations to whether or not you should be able
to shut yourself off because we can't commit suicide.
But Ken,
can a person who's downloaded their consciousness into an eternal machine,
can they figure out,
are they doing or could,
could you get some crazy guy like George,
um,
George Foreman who named all his kids?
George,
what a few like calling yourself a billion times.
You're just like one nutty dude who just decided to make a million of you and
set yourself loose on Cleveland.
There's a lot of science fiction that covers this is all posts,
singularity stuff.
And there's a lot of Scifi that covers this because you,
you lose grasp on,
on basic human things.
Like,
what does it mean to die if there's a thousand other copies of view?
What does it mean to have a daughter?
Well,
what happened?
Thousand copies?
What does it mean to be you?
How did you become you?
Are you collection of jeans?
Are you,
are you a reaction to your environment?
Like what are you,
there's people the meet them and go,
wow,
you're fucking cool.
Like where did you come from?
You know,
I love talking to you.
This isn't the,
and you like a million.
You could run into 500 people and not feel that and then run into one where you
just can't stop talking to them.
You know?
And it's like,
what makes that,
how do you make that?
What is,
what is,
what combination of things?
How has you hold onto that if you transferred and then whatever that magic is to
us,
you know,
that magic,
compelling,
sort of a charm is to us that's completely lost in the worlds of cold ones and
Zeros and machines.
Yeah.
My whole outlook on science and what it's there for is it's not a battle to
defeat human nature or to escape from our meat.
Our bodies are our fates.
Like I think it's there to amplify what we've already got.
You know,
like I think there's certainly that way.
Yeah.
I mean we're very low.
We're intellectual creatures,
right?
I mean we can live our lives in our heads and we can try to ignore our bodies
are think of our bodies as impediments,
but you know,
and I,
I don't work out.
I don't push my body to,
you know,
I don't compete physically with people,
but like I acknowledged that like I eat a shit.
Like I have sex,
I'm smart babies.
These are all crazy.
These are all things that human beings do.
Right.
And like to try to run away from that I think is,
is,
is crazy because you got to admit that you got to acknowledge your embodied as a
human being.
And if you give into that,
then you in some sense there's sort of fulfilling what you're there for.
You know?
It feels good to eat.
It feels good to go back.
These are,
because it's naturally,
you know,
just to play devil's advocate,
just play devil's advocate.
What we're talking about is the concept of you becoming some sort of an immortal
thing.
It doesn't do all the things that a human does.
Well what if you do do all the things that a human does?
It's just the,
we've recreated it and an art,
you know,
quote unquote artificial form and instead of it being,
a carbon based life form that occurred naturally.
It's something that we engineered to occur,
but it is the same goddamn thing.
So you,
it's not that you wouldn't shit,
it's not that you wouldn't eat this,
not that you wouldn't,
but you'd be doing it in a new body.
See the ultimate form of it.
If you're not in a human body right then,
but it would be a human body.
If you get transferred into like just a young human body or I think they're
going to be able to make buildings and I think they're going to be able to make
human bodies.
I think it's not with our idea of a robot.
I think we'll,
we'll certainly be able to make something that looks exactly like a human being,
but I think they're also going to be able to make a human being.
See,
you're asking me to put my money where my mouth is basically,
because you're saying no,
no,
but really I think you are because it's interesting to me because I haven't
thought about it this way,
but you're saying,
look Wilson,
if you think that because you're embodied as a human,
you're obligated to experience life as a human and do all the things humans do.
Well,
guess what?
All humans do,
they die.
Right?
So if you're saying that you really are,
are putting your money where your mouth is,
then you have to be willing to die.
Right.
And acknowledged that that's a natural part of what humans do.
And a part of accepting your embodiment as a human.
I don't know.
I don't know if it came down to it.
I might not want to go over the roller coaster.
Yeah,
I think we were.
We don't want to leave behind the ones we love.
That's one of the big things.
We don't want to leave leave behind the like that would be one of the saddest
things.
So your family being remorseful that you weren't around,
but the idea of what you're saying is you wouldn't want to be downloaded into
some machine where you didn't experience all the joys and the actual person
experiences.
What I'm saying is I think they're going to be able to create artificial human
beings that literally you will get a whole new body to download yourself into
and you will,
you will drink wine and you will enjoy it and you will like blow jobs and you
were like waterparks since going skiing and you were like doing all the things
that a person likes.
You'll just be doing it in this completely new physical existence that they've
created.
An artificial human being with boobs and a vagina.
Brian is,
Brian would progress.
They would,
they would have like this one freak group forum somewhere and Brian would be a
part of it.
You have a penis and vagina
come into my soul.
You know?
I still think doing that would violate a lot of,
a lot of what it means to be a human being.
Brian would have an excuse to be fat when he would do is he would put the vagina
like an inch below his belly button so he could fold it over and literally fuck
himself or just fucking belly button.
It just be your belly button.
Winder.
Yeah,
you could do that stuff on door knobs.
Wouldn't be as good guy,
but belly button wouldn't be as good.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's going to be really interesting to see what,
what form all of this,
you know,
quote unquote progress and technological innovation and where,
where it goes because no one from,
obviously from the lost in space days where we're just looking at that no one
saw this coming and they didn't see the internet coming.
They didn't see,
you know,
Twitter or you know,
Wifi.
They didn't see any of that stuff.
And who knows what we're missing.
Who knows what we like,
what one big thing that's going to change the whole ball of wax,
like just drones,
you know,
there,
there was no drones and those old movies like the star wars,
it was like a few things.
It would fly around like jets and shit and,
but not like,
like what is going to be in our cities and just a few decades
military is,
is not a bad idea because the arpanet was a Darpa project turned into the
Internet,
gps,
satellites,
all that stuff that was all military tech that eventually went public.
It would be so awesome with,
they weren't killing innocent people.
So vehicles is from a Darpa project.
So you know,
if that was from the future combat initiative that has since gone away,
they wanted a lot of autonomous caravans because they are tired of humans
getting blown up with IED.
They were like,
wow.
So look into the military is not a bad idea if you want to see what's coming
next for civilians.
The,
um,
the,
the real a spooky thing is the air force,
um,
drone aviary where they're a working on all these different size drones,
flapping wing drones,
drones,
it looked like a bird.
They literally flap their wings and move like a bird.
There was a video,
um,
oh,
they showed all the different ones they have now these dragon fly ones that fit
on the tip of your finger.
It's incredible.
If these things were flying around,
you wouldn't have no idea.
You would really think that that was a bug.
And then,
and that's just a couple of years away,
they're going to be everywhere filming everything.
Micro air vehicles when they get smaller than six inches,
uh,
the flight that like all the flight dynamics change.
And so you have to start looking at insects instead of birds.
Oh really?
So that's why the design changes like that.
And so that's all,
I mean,
they,
they studied the dynamics of how insects fly and then they try to replicate it.
Um,
yeah,
you really wouldn't be able to keep up those rpms at the higher like mass.
Like,
that's why I like a pterodactyl wouldn't fly like a,
like a dragon fly.
Like I'm not an expert an expert on this in particular,
but like from what I understand,
the way of fly actually flaps its wings is it's more of a scoop because it's
like dealing with such a small number of like particles of air and it's actually
on becomes almost more like a fluid.
Um,
the way that it's interacting and yeah,
you don't have to do that on a larger scale.
You can,
you can get lift,
you know,
without having to do that.
But the agility of a fly,
if you really wrap your head around it,
like when you try to swat a fly and he darts away from you,
it is mind blowing how well those fuckers can move with that crazy setup,
this little round body and these giant clear wings have a lot of high level
thought going into it.
We're just wired straight to their nervous system is to avoid obstacles.
I mean these are way easier to swat at a Scott and flies are killer bees.
You don't want that killer bee honey.
When you,
when you swat a be out of the sky though,
it's really not that much of an accomplishment.
If you can actually a swat a fly out of the sky and like,
Whoa,
bees kind of anticipates,
yeah,
flights are robots.
That's why flies and how many girls you don't want.
Man.
It flies were big.
We'd be fucking terrified.
The flies were from another planet and we found them.
If we,
if we like tuned into another planet and we got,
we sent a probe,
like we,
you know,
a light year away or whatever,
and they found giant insect forms.
If they were giant flies like flies the size of bowls.
Ooh,
that's pretty big.
I was reading terrifying.
That would be about this on like a io nine.com they had a deal about this
because insects used to be a lot bigger and it's apparently they,
you know,
they breathe through these little holes.
I can't remember what they're called,
but uh,
that's the way that they get oxygen.
Right.
And it used to be that there was more oxygen in the atmosphere and that's why
the bugs were all a shitload bigger dinosaurs are so big too,
because it would support their weight better.
Uh,
I dunno.
I don't think so.
No,
no.
I,
I'm not sure though,
but I know that the bugs,
because of the way they breathe specifically,
they don't have like lungs
like we do,
you know,
they have just little holes and I don't know exactly how it works,
but apparently whenever there's a lot of high oxygen,
you get like a ratio that's better for them.
Okay.
Well,
yeah,
it doesn't mean what I said doesn't make sense,
but I think there was a,
there was some question I took it from,
there was some question that the environment was thicker than the atmosphere was
thicker.
Um,
it was a very recent thing.
They were trying to figure out why they were so big.
Like what,
what led,
you know,
them to grow so large.
I forget what the,
uh,
the article was about I think,
but I think that was part of the,
uh,
part of the scenario that they're proposing was that something about the
atmosphere was much different and that it was easier to support giant forms of
life.
Then the other thing was like,
I guess like the trees and the vegetation was different back then.
And a lot of these animals were vegetable leaders.
And then if you're going to have a giant Brontosaurus,
if something's going to eat it,
it's gotta be like a TRX.
It's gotta be a Chai went fucking even bigger,
crazier thing.
So it's almost like the more plants you have to eat,
the bigger the things are that eat the plants and the bigger the things that eat
the things.
Yeah.
We were talking about this,
a documentary about a,
uh,
an area of Africa that's cut off the river,
changed its course just just a hundred years ago.
And this area has been isolated Kong action.
Well,
it's sort of,
it's,
it's lions and water buffaloes and the lions have grown larger because they have
to only take down water buffaloes.
Right.
So there's like one pack,
specifically a female lions that are biggest male lions.
They're enormous and it's all because they have to take down water buffalo.
It's like they've adapted to this one particular area.
Every animal is a solution to a problem,
but to robots,
that's the,
that's the question to robots and if they're going to have that engineered into
their system isn't,
aren't us the first shit they're going to get rid of?
Man?
I don't think so.
I think that they're just,
you know,
robots are tools and if we design them well,
they'll do it.
The fuckers are going to take over.
Dude,
do you believe that I type scenario where there's going to be people that don't
even know that they're robots?
Yeah.
You hope you get married.
One of those,
bring one of those in.
Look,
she's just going to stay with us for a while.
He just makes out with you when no one's around and then she's cleans.
Yeah.
It's like what we're going to eventually have to deal with the,
the moral aspects of ordering,
ordering them around,
helping them as slaves,
them sex,
sex tools.
I think that the human,
and I think that robots have the potential to be more human than we are to be
more moral than we are and to like be great examples for our children to raise
our children.
I think that I think we're going to become very,
very,
very intimate with these machines.
And can you stack your robot and then it's gonna make you real but fuck you and
kiss a kid.
Do you think it's ever possible that robots can be funny?
Will they have ever figured that out?
Is that a mathematical yeah,
I said that.
Is that a problem?
Is that what that is like?
Yeah,
you could build,
you can build a learner that would try to figure out what's funny specifically
and tell jokes.
I'm sure people have done that.
I bet if you look for that you find it.
I wonder if like it like a robot could craft a bunch of things that were
specifically funny because um,
you know,
we always want to think that a,
well there's certain things you can't do.
You can't recruit talent.
Maybe we can,
I mean,
maybe it was just like paintings.
Maybe we're just symphonies very rudimentary right now in our thoughts on what
robotics are or what artificial intelligence is.
But why would we think that we're so special that we can recreate it?
I mean it's really kind of arrogant.
I know.
And it's a losing battle,
right?
It's like every year there's a new thing that they can do and like we're slowly
shrinking down and you know,
at the end of the day,
the only thing that might be left as is that morality,
that ability to be good or evil,
that that lump of meat that has to sit behind the steering wheel to take the
blame.
Yeah.
All we have to offer and we have to figure out what is that fourth even why,
why does that exist?
What is it,
you know,
what,
what is it showing us about the human race where there is like there's a
positivity and there's energy to be derived from good behavior and from healthy
behavior.
It's just very difficult to teach that to people.
And if you negatively reinforce it and give them a lot of negative energy in
their life and a lot of negative experiences than they recreate that,
that sort of energy.
And they go after it over and over again.
They get addicted to a certain pattern.
And uh,
that's,
uh,
that's the number one issue with engineering human beings,
period.
Forget about robots.
We haven't even figured out how to get the human meat machine to operate in the
correct manner.
That's the great thing about humans,
right?
We have the,
we think at least that we have the free will and then we can be good or evil.
You know,
if you program a robot to be good no matter what,
then it's not good.
It's just doing it.
That's interesting.
That's like a lot of trust.
I mean,
if we ever have a machine that's capable of,
of doing that,
I mean that is like,
that's like creating life.
But if you say that,
say go out and do good or evil and then I'm going to see what what you do.
And you know,
that's some more biblical themes right there.
It really is,
right?
Yeah.
And that it really is biblical.
I mean,
you really are creating a life form.
If we,
if you were 52 years old and he had been divorced several times and yet almost
no money left and somebody gave you a beautiful robot,
suck slave that didn't want to vote and had no personality of its own,
just existed to fulfill your sexual needs,
maybe then you'd understand.
But right now you're a young man with hoping your eyes and dreams for the
future.
If you were broken by a steady stream of bad relationship choices and divorces
and you were living in a fucking shack outside of Palmdale with a car that's
broken down,
you wouldn't think twice about that robot fucked all.
You'd be like,
I'm out of the dating scene for life.
Do you think that will life make people happy or no,
but they rather they'd probably drown her and,
uh,
you know,
and you know,
kill themselves and in the process,
I dunno.
I think that,
um,
it's very hard for people to be happy.
And one of the things that people need in order to be happy in my opinion,
is that you need happy people in your life.
You need to surround yourself with happy people.
That alone is very difficult fine because finding a group of people that have
managed to maneuver and managed to carve a path through life that's been
generating the majority of what the people that are encountering with are
enjoying their company.
The majority of it is a positive experience.
Uh,
goals have been fulfilled.
You know,
health is an order.
All those different things,
all those variables that have to be in place in order to find a truly happy
person.
It's really difficult to accumulate a bunch of people like that and then get
together.
So occasionally,
like many of us in,
in our lives have known there are certain people we have to cut off.
You know,
there's,
there's a certain point in time,
you know,
okay,
this person is an energy vampire.
They never get in their own shit together.
You've got to cut me off for one.
You got Pee pee man.
See Sun.
I can hold my bladder strong.
My Goldberg.
You hear that?
Yeah,
please go.
Go through.
Right that their door and there's a door on the left.
See Dude,
I ramble so hard to make people pee their pants.
That's how I do son.
Uh,
people are requesting a Brian Red and Joe Rogan only podcast for number 300.
We have coming up.
Yeah,
it's coming in,
dude.
I think we only have like a couple more weeks.
We're at like,
what,
what number is this?
84.
That's ridiculous son.
We should,
uh,
see if we could coincide it somehow or another.
We timed them out.
Right.
We can,
uh,
coincided with the end of the month,
which is when we started in the first place,
right?
A J January.
We started January or December 31st.
Yeah.
It was like New Year's Eve.
I think they'll,
they'll,
they'll probably know before us,
but it seems like that'll wind up around there.
You know,
we should probably time it to the shin.
Yeah,
that'd be cool.
And so we'll do a three year anniversary.
We've been doing this for three years.
That's crazy.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
I've got a p two do you have any robot questions for this too?
Probably taking a big stink or there he was taking them all one off.
It might be beaten off.
All this talk about sex robots and robot fucked dolls in the Palmdale desert.
Let's check the toilet cam.
I think a robot fuck dolls.
It was probably going to be on the first things that people invent besides
maids.
You're going to learn if you can make like a terror Patrick looking made,
you're going to fuck it.
It's going to clean your house and you're gonna fuck.
I think it's going to start off as a pet at first.
It's going to be some kind of like animal,
like a cat.
I got a beat too,
man.
We're talking about Tara Patrick as a robot that you can fuck.
Elaborate please.
Tara Patrick.
Oh,
I'm taking over now.
Huh?
Your grind.
Yeah.
Uh,
so what do you think about the of garden?
I think the Olive Garden's pretty,
pretty nice.
You know that there's a list of companies including the olive garden and red
lobster where they're like cutting everyone's hours so they don't have to give
them health care.
Have you heard about this?
It's like red lobster,
olive garden,
like all these legit companies and they just,
because of the Obamacare,
they're cutting everyone's hours.
It's pretty fucking weird watching these companies do that.
It's sort of weird because of you see that there,
the con the corporations have rebounded and they've got all this money but
they're still not like quite trusting that the economy is better.
So there's,
there's sort of sticking with all the cuts they made and sort of like,
you know,
riding that as long as they can.
Do you collect robots?
Do you have like a collection of toys or like,
you know,
or people give me robots a lot cause you know,
I'm the robot guy.
I've been studying them and you know,
so I have a lot of them around the house.
Like,
but I don't have to collect them myself.
I do like some of the robot art.
You know Eric Joiner,
he does all these robots and donuts.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's pretty Rad.
I remember the first robot I ever created,
I back in the day that you had an erector set,
and I don't know if you remember that.
It used to be like this yellow case that you would open up and inside were like
these miscellaneous motors and like metal pieces that you could put together.
And one of the things that they give you instructions for is how to build a
robot.
And this robot was just like,
uh,
I think it had like eyeballs that were light bulbs and it moved and stuff.
But as a kid and was like,
I built my own robot.
They were like a lot of eighties robot kits that you could buy.
And they were like,
look,
it's a robot,
right?
You're going to get a robot.
And then you get it and you're like,
I don't know,
nerds,
you know,
they have that robot and you're like,
really?
You remember Napoleon dynamite where the uncle got a time machine?
He kept writing,
right?
Yes.
It's like that stuff.
I told a friend and meet me at five,
but I got a text him real quick.
I'm so sorry.
Oh,
that's old.
We actually,
I almost five minutes.
Oh,
okay.
Well just really,
oh,
almost oh time.
10 minutes,
man.
Yeah,
it was a long ass podcast dude.
Um,
listen,
if anybody wants to get ahold of you,
they can get ahold of you on Twitter.
Um,
your,
uh,
your Twitter is,
what is it again?
It's Daniel Wilson PDX Daniel Wilson PDX lays.
I have to repeat it just in case they didn't hear you,
even though you were very clear.
Daniel Wilson PDX folks,
and you can,
uh,
also,
go to his website,
which is Daniel Wilson,
Daniel h wilson.com.
And the book is robot apocalypse cockpit in Robo popularity in Germany.
It's called robocall lips because the Po means ass.
Oh,
really?
The German editors were like,
Hey,
uh,
so we don't really want it to be like robot ass apocalypse.
Yeah,
that sounds perfect.
That sounds better,
man.
Why don't mind,
I might have to do a rewrite sensor in Uman.
The fucking,
the man is trying to keep you from selling books.
That's,
that's fucked up dude.
Um,
and um,
this,
um,
an amp does the other book,
right?
Yeah.
It's on kindle or,
and all that stuff right there in bookstores or on Amazon.
And it's actually on audible.
I got one of those Barnes and noble nooks.
It's pretty bad ass dude.
I got it when I was in San Francisco.
I like it when you get a real tablet.
We're talking about,
I liked that too,
man.
But I like for reading,
you know what I like about it?
That it looks like,
it looks like print on paper.
It doesn't have that look of like an LCD screen.
Yeah.
You know,
the way,
uh,
the kindles look,
you know,
Kendall's of the noax,
they both have that sort of same paper paper look.
Yeah.
I liked that.
I think it's less,
less eye strain for free,
but when you can get your shit on that,
right?
Yeah.
Everything.
And what I love about that is on kindle,
if you like highlight something,
you know,
and the book,
then that stuff can be shared.
And so I can actually see what people are highlighting in the book and like see
what they like and if people comment about it.
So let's see.
You know,
that's some stupid shit.
how do they do that?
When they highlight it and share it,
what do they do?
Well then you have to have your settings to,
to share.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
What a great idea.
It's pretty cool as an author to be able to go on to Amazon and it's,
and like see what people are reading and that's some new stuff and see the exact
quotes that people responding to standup comic.
Like sometimes you'll say something and I show him the next night someone will
quote it and they'll be laughing.
And you,
Oh yeah,
I forgot I even said that.
You know,
it's,
it becomes,
uh,
these,
these quoted things.
When you,
uh,
when you see your stuff highlighted and you see like the things that people,
really enjoy or didn't enjoy,
how much does that affect your next writing?
Do you do really look a lot at the feedback and try to like see it from their
point of view?
Oh Man,
I,
it affects my readings cause I'll try to go read when I do a reading I'll try to
read like the part that people,
like I said,
I think I'm smart,
right.
Good at writing.
But uh,
so it affects like which excerpts you choose.
Reading what I'm writing,
man,
I just like I,
when I'm nerding out and I'm like all super excited,
then I know I'm doing it right.
Basically.
Yeah.
Isn't that the coolest thing in the world?
Like when you're writing and an idea comes into your head and you just following
it down and it's like building and growing like right before your eyes,
being able to create something and being able to come up with some shit that
didn't exist before and then boom,
then all of a sudden it does.
It's a,
it's such an unbelievably satisfying experience and then it's there and it hangs
around it.
You got it like and like I did this,
this is what I did in like 2009 it's right there.
It's a thing I made.
Yeah.
That's why.
When,
if you have a job where you're able to create and then also make some kind of
artifact,
you know that you have and say I did that New York Times bestselling book and on
top of that people can continue to buy it.
It's always available.
They're going to always get it.
If they can get it in hard form,
they can get into the digital form.
They can keep getting it.
It's pretty curious about this movie is going to do for it.
Oh,
it's going to blow through the roof.
If you just only had a few bitches getting raped,
choked and gags and ball gagged and a mouth fucked,
you just kind of have them abused a little bit more.
Do your books go in order at all?
If I'm right by him or no.
So rub apocalypse in amped are two different theories on this 50 shades of grey
thing and why women are into getting their mouth spit and stuff like that.
What does this change?
What is,
what's going on here?
Yeah,
I mean,
what do you think,
right?
Because,
well,
it's interesting that it started out as fan fiction,
but this was Edward and Bella.
You didn't know that.
Oh No,
I did not.
Book was fan fiction.
Shut the fuck up.
The leash shades of grey started out with twilight.
Yes,
it had the,
all they did literally was changed the names of the characters and then they
published it.
Don is ridiculous.
That's the most silly thing I've ever heard in my life.
It's the real deal.
So it was someone who was really into that and they just followed on that tone
and created like a sexual bondage version of it.
I wonder,
maybe that's what's the undercurrent,
right?
I mean,
so it's like twilight has a story,
you know,
and it has all this stuff,
but there's obviously a deep sexual undercurrent.
It's a love story.
Right?
And so this lady just went for the Juggler.
She's forget all the bullshit,
right,
to like fuck vampires.
Okay,
let's say he's a billionaire.
He's a financial plan pie that it's all just about fucking,
you know,
maybe that's it.
Maybe if you,
you know,
it's just humans are not as complicated as we like to think.
Maybe that's what it's really about.
I certainly think that's the case,
but I also think that women want to hear shit that's in their voice.
So like most pornography I think is from the male voice.
I just bought his book.
Nice.
I still got Ernie Ernie Cline applications.
Oh yeah.
If you've read that book.
Sure.
I love I'm,
I'm,
I blurbed it,
my blurbs on that book somewhere.
Do you think apple will ever shrink that bitch down so it fits in your pocket?
It does fit in my pocket.
You're like your pants check.
What comes down to brands?
Apple brand pants.
Can you get some apple pants?
Wait.
Okay.
If you sit,
if you sit down,
that was going to break and it's going to cut your Dick in half.
Oh my God.
It's one man.
It's what
you will will be one man,
one iPad.
Don't ever take that out when you're drunk but if you have like a a nice man
purse,
you can carry that around easily.
You shoot can you know?
You should know you're going to die.
You should commit to a man purse.
Commit to a man purse so you're a big proponent of that using that because you
can get online with it.
You can do photos,
everything.
It does pretty much everything.
I got the non sell your one because I have an iPhone that has a hotspot but I
think more that I'm using the hot spot feature on the iPhone.
I think I would if you were going to get do get the one with the cell phone
service built into it.
It's just kind of more of a pain in the butt.
Like oh I gotta turn on my hot spot.
That's what I was thinking.
I was thinking that we probably better to wait for the other version of it but
as as compared to the IPADS,
I have both of them definitely.
I love this one better.
I carry it's enough.
That is what you need,
right?
It's like what was crazy when we were in Seattle.
Well and we were streaming from it.
We streamed to Ustream show from it.
Yeah.
We lost Daniel.
Sorry.
Do you,
do you give a fuck about this kind of stuff or are you just holding into
robotics?
I uh,
whatever.
Yeah,
no,
what I'm saying I,
I'm not,
I don't really collect a lot of gadgets.
No Real,
I have this thing that is like the Magna doodle,
you know,
where you,
you,
you use the little magnet thing and you draw on it and that's like the closest
thing to about two an I pad,
but it's like at my house right now.
The clown or what's the one?
The client.
It is a totally from like my kid.
Yeah.
It's pretty bad ass.
Light.
Bright.
Honestly,
I'm just scared because it changes everything.
Every time you get one,
you know like already I'm not,
if I,
if I look at the stupid phone you saw that I forget about everything.
I'm like a little retarded.
When someone has a new one,
five minutes,
we're almost done.
If someone has a new one man,
like I'm drawn to it like a baby.
And that's the other thing.
Little kids love it.
So if you bring it up,
it's like bringing crack home.
It's May you're done.
And I'm kind of afraid of how it will affect my kids too cause I just
educational shows on there and there's educational does games that they can
count.
They learn how to count
a certain feline companion enjoys using the IPAD.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
My cat plays with my iPad and pisses all over my couch and that's not a
euphemism.
I can't play with my iPad.
And then she pisses all over my couch with a black guy.
A black gentleman
was name is William [inaudible].
IPAD was born in the 40 [inaudible] right.
This is all one pocket play.
It's actually Katt Williams.
Oh Try Williams.
Okay.
Upside.
No
Gentlemen,
I think we gave out all the information.
We probably could.
Uh,
Daniel H.
Wilson PDX on Twitter.
Wilson.
Oh it's no,
it's Daniel Wilson.
PDX on quit on Twitter,
not Daniel H.
Wilson.
So Daniel Wilson PDX on Twitter.
Daniel h wilson.com.
Thanks a lot man.
It's been really fun.
It was a fun conversation.
Really interesting stuff.
And if you ever have anything you want to promote,
want to come back,
do it again.
We'll be happy to have you on.
Dude.
I had a great time.
Sorry I had to urinate so I had it too.
Once you did it,
you broke the ice.
But we know it's fucking three hours.
We don't even take commercial breaks,
you know?
But I think it makes for a better conversation that way.
It's hard to,
it's hard to take a commercial break and then come back and we'll just pick up
where you were.
Just seems awkward,
you know?
So we do it this way and it requires people hold their bladder.
I keep it together.
I think he did an excellent job though.
You had a big thing of water.
You lasted like two hours,
let's say.
Pretty strong.
Thank you guys so much.
You're welcome man.
Thank you in a great time.
And uh,
one more time.
The,
the two books,
your books are Robo,
apocalypse and amped.
And those are the ones that you're promoting,
right?
But you have more than that,
How many books you're off all together.
Eight go by and bitches go get him on an audible go get.
Oh yeah.
Do you have them on audible?
Beautiful.
Go to audible.com and if you go to audible com forward slash Joe,
you can get a free book and you get a 30 day a free membership
to a one of the best services,
the I think online as far as like with the audio entertainment.
Love it.
I love audible.com I love the idea behind it and they have a massive selection
including this young man's fantastic real but books,
so he'll get it.
You're dirty bitches.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t.
Go and get yourself some new mood bitch or some Alpha brain and the things.
If you have any questions about these supplements,
there's a 100% money back guarantee on the first 30 pills.
You don't even have to return the product.
No one's trying to rip you off and just trying to save you the looking for the
best shit possible.
Sell you all this stuff that I would use.
Use the code name Rogan and you will save yourself 10% all right,
let's fucking shows over.
Oh,
if you use the code named Sandy,
we'll take that 10% and we'll donate it towards hurricane relief.
Uh,
we actually decided to go with the salvation army cause in this case the
salvation army is using 100% of the proceeds for hurricane relief is like a lot
of them that it actually gets down the leg as low as like 30% actually goes to
the people in the victims.
But Salvation Army,
in this case it's 100% so we're going with them.
If you use the code named Sandy.
Alright fuckers,
we might see you tomorrow.
We've got a lot of work to do.
What?
We're going to be a at the new studio,
a Titan and shit down.
Brian and I are just starting to set that place.
I was not quite done yet.
Uh,
it takes time.
Bitches takes time.
But I'll see you guys all in Montreal for sure.
This Friday at the metropolis with Duncan Trussell.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
So,
yeah,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.